Und das am heutigen Mittwoch und da heißt es wieder Chaosradio. Mein Name ist Jens Quantalo und herzlich willkommen. Und ja, Chaos und Radio. Ich bin heute für das Chaos zuständig. Radio machen heute die Chaos Leute vom Chaos Computer Club. Und damit übergebe ich gleich an Tim. Ich bin nur die Festplatte im Hintergrund, im Background.
Die Radikal hat es uns allen gezeigt. Ist dem Gesetzgeber eine Meinung im Dorn im Auge, so wird auch sofort dagegen vorgegangen. Konnte man früher noch einfach den Vertrieb unterbinden, so ist das in Zeiten von World Wide Web und elektronischer Post ein Problem. Eine Zensur kann technisch nicht stattfinden, schon gar nicht im Privatbereich. Oder doch? Wie ist das eigentlich, wenn ihr jemanden einen privaten Brief schreiben wollt? Nehmt ihr dann eine Postkarte? Wohl kaum. Passt ja auch nicht so viel drauf. Und außerdem könnte jeder, der es in der Hand hat, lesen. Wer schon mal beim GILB die Säcke geschleppt hat, weiß, wie es mit der Unverletzlichkeit privater Kommunikation steht. Schlecht. Und wer es genauer wissen will, sollte mal ein paar Zehn-Mark-Scheine im Normalbriefumschlag verschicken. Auf dem Internet und anderen Datennetzen wird Post mittlerweile in Terabytes gemessen. Mehr und mehr geschäftliche Kommunikation und auch Privates macht die Runde. Und was machen, wenn es privat ist? Der Schutzumschlag der Datenwelt heißt Verschlüsselung. Damit er wirkungsvoller als Klarsichthöhlen ist, muss er eine weitgehende Angriffs-Sicherheit bieten, die sich in Verfahren und Schlüssellänge niederschlinkt. Entschlüsselt mit uns im Chaosradio. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio im März. Zensur elektronischer Medien ist unser Thema heute. Ich weiß, das ist zumindest das, was wir angekündigt haben. Wir haben es leicht verändert aus gegebenen Anlass. Kontrolle elektronischer Medien wollen wir das heute ein bisschen erweitert wissen. Wir fahren heute in der alten Stammbesetzung.
Na ja, fast.
Fast. Ich bin Tim, hallo. Und dann haben wir noch dabei.
Andi und Steini und Frank sitzt hinten und tippt noch fleißig die Meldung.
Und Frank tippt noch ein bisschen.
Und Tim ist nämlich heute unser Star-Moderator, weil Johnny, der rennt irgendwo in der Weltgeschichte rum und kann heute leider nicht. Da müssen wir das machen.
Genau. Und ich kümmere mich darum, dass die anderen nicht so viel dummes Zeug kriegen. Kontrolle elektronischer Medien. Wir wollen uns heute im Wesentlichen über zwei Themen unterhalten, versuchen das auch zunächst einmal stark zu trennen. Wir haben heute auch einen großen Unterschied zu anderen Sendungen. Wir werden heute sehr viel mehr Telefon-Interviews führen. Das heißt, wir haben ein paar Leute, die da draußen darauf vorhatten, dass wir sie anrufen und zu aktuellen Themen befragen.
Und zwar sind das zum einen die Zensurgeschichten, die gerade ganz akut sich niedergeschlagen haben in Österreich, wo sich sozusagen ein ganzer Internet-Service-Provider verhaftet wurde. Teilweise haben wir gleich einen Betroffenen zu ans Telefon kriegen. Das ist aber nur der eine Themenkomplex. Also Zensur, wie gehen die Staatsanwaltschaften der verschiedenen Länder mit Zeitschriften, wie radikal, mit pornografischen Materialien und Ähnlichem um. Und der andere Themenkomplex ist dann, was da noch so drum herum passiert. Da werden eine Menge Gesetze geschaffen, die dieses zarte Flänzchen Internet dann erstmal einbetonieren. Das ist von Telekommunikationsgesetz, Informations- und Kommunikationsdienstgesetz. Naja, jedenfalls die ganzen Gesetze, die ich jetzt nicht aufführen werde, werden da noch ein bisschen erläutert werden. Und wir machen eine kleine europäische Rundreise im Rahmen unserer Telefon-Interviews. Also zunächst mal Österreich, die aktuelle Geschichte, und dann ein bisschen die Hintergründe. Dann werden wir in die Radikalgeschichte ein bisschen genauer reingehen. Da hat es ja in Holland einiges gegeben, wo die Zeitschrift übrigens legal ist und wo auch der Service Provider sich eigentlich nicht richtig strafbar macht, aber das ist eben kompliziert. Und da haben wir auch dann nachher den Rob von Access for All. Und später werden wir dann unsere Rundreise abschließen mit einem Abstecher in Berlin bei Interactive Networks, bei sozusagen dem größten Provider hier in Berlin, der nochmal ein bisschen erzählen wird, was dann hier in dieser unserer Stadt so passiert.
So, wir haben also ein volles Programm.
Ach ja, und dann noch das zweite Thema. Das sollten wir nicht vergessen, weil dann wollten wir nämlich noch umleiten zu...
Dann kündige doch weiter an, Andy.
Genau, weil nachdem wir dann nämlich diese Zensur und Kontrollegeschichte und ein bisschen in die Gesetze hineingegangen sind, wollten wir dann auch noch fragen, was kann man dann eigentlich sozusagen als betroffener Benutzer tun? Wie gehen wir jetzt als Bewohner dieses Netzes damit um? Stichwort Verschlüsselung. Was droht uns da? Warum wollen uns irgendwelche Politiker die Verschlüsselung womöglich einschränken? Oder wie sieht es überhaupt mit unserer Freiheit im Cyber Space aus? Und da kommen wir dann allerdings so ganz am Schluss in der dritten Stunde zu. Und eine Vorwarnung gleich vorweg. Wir werden Hörer, also euch dort draußen am Radio als Fragende, als interaktive Elemente dieser Sendung erst nach unseren vier Telefon-Interviewpartnern sozusagen zulassen.
Sonst kriegen wir das nämlich alles nicht auf die Art her.
Ja, das geht einfach nicht anders, weil die können größtenteils unsere Sendung gar nicht hören. Und mit denen haben wir jetzt mehr oder weniger feste Zeiten vereinbart. Und die müssen wir einhalten und danach können wir wieder chaosbunt mit interaktivem Hörer beifragen.
Aber Andi, die schöne Formulierung, das zarte Pflänzchen Internet, finde ich ganz hervorragend. In Wirklichkeit, um die andere Seite zu beleuchten, tummelt sich ja im Internet tatsächlich eine ganze Menge. Ja, so auch eben eine ganze Menge Schund.
Die Franzen sind dann immer lebendig, die wachsen und da irgendwie... Vielleicht sollten wir ein kurzes Versprechen vorher noch einlösen. Es ist ja auch das erste Chaosradio direkt nach der CeBIT. Der Chaos Computer Club war dieses Jahr das erste Mal mit einem eigenen Stand auf der CeBIT vertreten. Wir haben auch einige von euch da draußen an dem Stand begrüßen können, was uns natürlich sehr gefreut hat, obwohl es halt nicht im Berliner Raum war, sondern eben in Hannover. Anni, vielleicht mal kurz noch eine kurze Zusammenfassung der CeBIT aus deiner Sicht.
Also das ist jetzt echt subjektiv, weil ich hab mir diese CeBIT ja eine Woche lang gegeben, also richtig jeden Tag mehr oder weniger 24 Stunden Einsatz mit Anfahrt, Abbau und dem ganzen Quatsch. Und ich war nach der Messe doch zumindest so entgeistert von diesem Planeten, weil im Internet selbst, also wenn man sich vor so einem Computer bewegt, dann kann man das ja noch einigermaßen relativieren. Bloß wenn man eine Woche CeBIT hat und dann irgendwie nach Hause fährt, und feststellt, man hat im Grunde genommen in dieser Computerszene nur zwei Sachen zu tun, mit Maschinen und mit Männern. Und es hat mich einfach total angekotzt. Also ich war einfach danach, ich hatte überhaupt keine Lust mehr, ich hab mir echt überlegt, ob ich nicht vielleicht, ich hab danach einen Freund getroffen, der managte so eine kleine Rockband, da kurz vor Berlin, right now. Und der hat irgendwie, verstehst du, da passiert noch irgendwie was, da hat er irgendwie Frauen, da ist irgendwie Kultur. Der kommt irgendwie umhergereist. Ja, aber das ist irgendwie, verstehst du, er macht im Grunde genommen, ja ich bin ein bisschen frustriert gewesen, weil er macht im Grunde genommen ein bisschen dasselbe wie ich. Er administriert halt, kümmert sich darum, dass seine Leute da irgendwie Auftritte haben und macht so Geschichtchen. Und das klingt echt alles ein bisschen bunter, hab ich mir überlegt, weil im Grunde genommen ist ja alles schön und gut. Bloß wie gesagt Maschinen und Männer, also irgendwie da muss nochmal irgendwie mehr bunte, ja. Also wie gesagt, das war ganz subjektiv und steinig.
Ich soll jetzt was über die, ich war am Anfang gar nicht da.
Nix Neues. Also ich meine, da liefen die selben Menschen rum, wie die letzten Jahre auch nach meinem Eindruck. Da war irgendwie im Grunde genommen dieselbe Technik, dieselbe Atmosphäre. Das Schöne an der Cebit, was ich schön finde, ist, dass sozusagen die Informationsflussgeschwindigkeit einfach stark zunimmt. Also wenn irgendwas passiert, wenn man eine Frage hat, oder wenn wir wie auf der Cebit, auf dieser Cebit jetzt, da hatten wir so eine Homebanking-Geschichte, wo es irgendwie so Unsicherheitsgeschichten gab, da konnte man das sofort klären. Da war dann gleich einer von der Bank 24 bei uns aufgestanden und einer von einer betroffenen Softwarefirma und wir haben uns angebrüllt und das war richtig Spaß. Und ja, weil im normalen Leben, da muss man irgendwie erst mal telefonieren, dann hört man, die haben eine Stellungnahme abgegeben und so, da ist das also so langsam und zähflässig. Und auf so einer Cebit, wo wirklich alle Menschen mehr oder weniger einer bestimmten Szene dieser Computerkommunikation, sonst wie Szene vertreten sind, da geht das alles viel schneller. Und das ist irgendwie schon schön, aber wie gesagt, wenn man dann noch verstellt, dass das alle so nehmen.
Also, ich resümiere mal die Cebit, es hat sich jetzt deutlich gezeigt auf dieser Cebit mehr als auf jeder anderen vorher, dass der Trend irgendwie eigentlich eher weg von Sicherheit hin zu Unsicherheit zu eigentlich doch egal. Eigentlich bildet sich die Realität immer mehr im Netz ab. Kommerzielle Interessen haben immer mehr Vorsprung vor irgendwelchen Illegalistischen und so weiter. Das ist eigentlich der Trend, der mir auf der Cebit am deutlichsten geworden ist.
Also um es kurz zu machen, 1984 wird langsam Realität und zu Zensur kommen wir dann gleich. Chaosradio im März, unser Thema Zensur und Kontrolle elektronischer Medien. Andy, ist denn Zensur überhaupt schon ein aktuelles Thema? Hat es da schon Fälle gegeben? Wie ist denn der Stand der Dinge?
Na ja, man muss erstmal zwei Komplexe sozusagen unterscheiden. Es gibt einmal Sachen, die sind zweifelsfrei, illegal und zwar mehr oder weniger überall. Zum Beispiel Kinderpornografie. Da braucht man ganz international überhaupt nicht drüber zu diskutieren. Das ist auf jedem Planeten, quatscht auf jedem Land, illegal. In jegweiter Form im Sinne von Produktion, Verbreitung der Bilder, Verkauf und so weiter und so fort.
Oder auch Besitz.
Oder auch, na, Vorsicht, nicht überall. Ich sagte ja gerade, das, was überall, also das gibt es im Internet, das heißt Weltrecht nennt sich das. Und dann gibt es den weniger eindeutigen Bereich und das sind die, ich nenne es mal nationale Empfindlichkeiten. Das ist zum Beispiel die deutsche Regierung, die mit der Zeitschrift radikal ein Problem hat hingegen. Zum Beispiel in Holland, das völlig legal ist. Oder...
Was ist die, was ist radikal?
Radikal ist eine dem linksextremistischen Spektrum zugerechnete Zeitschrift, die also a, politisch wohl recht bissig ist und b, dann auch nicht davor zurückschreckt, wenn sie schon über Transportnuklearen, Materials mit der deutschen Bundesbahn berichten, dann auch gleich eine Anleitung zu machen, die man zu entgleisen lässt und solche Geschichten.
Ist die denn in Deutschland überhaupt zu haben, die Zeitschrift?
Die ist irgendwie zu haben, aber die wird nicht so richtig... Also die Produzenten werden als terroristische Vereinigung mittlerweile verfolgt und als solche ist die Zeitschrift also nicht generell verboten, aber jedes einzelne Exemplar ist bisher verboten gewesen, aufgrund dem einen oder anderen Aufruf, die Strafverfahren...
Ich glaube auch dann aber auch der Besitz, wenn ich da richtig informieren will.
Ja, das kann schon sein, aber da...
Zumindest wenn man als Verteiler auftrat und mehr als einer hatte, dann soll das...
Man kann sie auch auf Papier abonnieren, die wird von Holland aus verschickt, weil sie da eben legal ist und man bekommt sie dann mit neutraler Post wohl aus Holland zugeschickt. Aber das ist nicht der Punkt. Also was ich sagen will ist, erst mal als sozusagen grobe Problem, weil zu radikaler kommen wir später noch ein bisschen, da haben wir ja einen ganz konkreten Fall. Es gibt also bestimmte Sachen, die sind in Ländern legal und in anderen Ländern nicht. Das sind diese nationalen Erfindlichkeiten. Genauso wie in Amerika gibt es diese Freedom of Speech. Nach denen ist Nazi-Propaganda völlig okay. Also auch die Verleugnung des Holocaust und so fort ist da einfach legal.
Wobei Freedom of Speech ein grundsätzliches amerikanisches Recht ist und nicht eine Eigenschaft des Internethandlings in dem Fall ist.
Nein, richtig. Das sind eben unterschiedliche nationale Umgangsweisen, genauso wie die chinesische Regierung beispielsweise ein Problem damit hat, wenn über den politischen Führungsstil ihrer Regierung diskutiert wird oder die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate mit religiösen Diskussionen, wie sie in deutschen Grundschulen oder Universitäten geführt haben, auch ein Problem haben. Das sind halt aber international nicht rechtlich irgendwie eindeutige Geschichten. Und das ist das, wo die Juristen im Moment sehr reich werden und wo wir irgendwie sozusagen ein großes Problem haben werden. Und die Frage ist da sozusagen, was will man jetzt erstmal vom Grundsätzlichen her? Wir haben jetzt also dieses Internet, einen globalen Kulturraum, der sich einfach nicht darum schert, ob er jetzt in Deutschland ist, in England ist, oder aber Informationen zwischen verschiedenen Ländern transportiert oder einfach nur zwischen verschiedenen Computern, die in einem und demselben Raum stehen. Das macht ja einfach alles technisch überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Und da fangen die Probleme sozusagen an. Und die Frage ist ja, was will man jetzt erreichen? Will man irgendwie diese nationalen Empfindlichkeiten beibehalten und die Zeitung radikal, also in Deutschland gar nicht haben? Oder wie soll das funktionieren? Das Netz hat blöderweise die Eigenschaft, sich darum nicht zu kümmern. Es kümmert sich nicht darum, in welchem Land es ist. Und wenn eine Instanz jetzt irgendwie sagt, diese Newsgroup transportieren wir nicht oder diese Webseiten machen wir nicht zugänglich, dann ist das im Zweifelsfall ein Störfall, ein Fehler und der wird dann halt umgangen. Der ist zumindest technisch umgehbar für jemand, der an die Information heran will. Und das heißt, mit der Umsetzung dieser nationalen Grenzen sozusagen ins elektronische, das haut schon mal nicht hin.
Da gab es ja zu dem Thema auch schon vermehrt Stimmmeldungen, auch hier in Deutschland. Gab es nicht auch eine Stellungnahme des Innenministeriums, dass man schon durchaus der Auffassung sei, dass das sich auch tatsächlich technisch nicht durchsetzen ließe?
Naja, also die Politiker hinken da zunächst einmal, muss man mal ganz bürzartig behaupten, mit dem Verständnis hinterher. Für die sind die neuen Medien, so wie wir sie jetzt mal nennen, also das Internet im Wesentlichen, elektronische Medien, im Grunde genommen genauso wie die alten Medien, also wie Bücher, Zeitschriften, Fernsehsender oder sonst was. Die glauben also noch, man kann sagen, hier sind die Sender, da sind die Empfänger, und hier sind die Grenzen, und so muss man das dann durchsetzen. Also zunächst einmal ist das ganz schwierig. Dann der Herr Rütkars beispielsweise, unser Bundesforschungsminister, das Bundesministerium für Forschung, Technologie und ähnliches, der hat mal so eine Presseerklärung rausgemacht, das Internet ist kein rechtsfreier Raum und kann alles gar nicht angehen. Also da dachte man schon, da geht einer irgendwie los, mit ganz anderen Parolen, die man aus ganz anderen Zeitaltern kennt. Aber so richtige Konzepte haben die nicht, und was ich ein bisschen erschreckender finde, ist auch die Parteien, wo man jetzt irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt wenigstens hier eine Aufzählung machen könnte, und sagen könnte, die CDU sieht das so, die CSU sieht das so, die SPD sieht das so, die Grünen sehen das so, all das ist leider nicht der Fall. Sondern es gibt immer noch für einzelne Leute, es gibt den Taus bei der SPD, der sagen wir mal unser positional steht, der sagt also diese ganzen alten Konzepte sind doch überholt. Und im Netz gibt es nun mal keine Grenzen, das heißt man muss sich darauf besinnen, was ist sinnvoll zu verfolgen, was ist irgendwie im Sinne, was weiß ich, Kinderpornos, keine Frage, da muss irgendwie der Urheber verfolgt werden. Aber bei irgendwie Nazi-Propaganda, die aus Amerika kommt, was soll man da tun? Das was der Amerikaner tut oder der Ernst Zündel zum Beispiel, der sitzt in Kanada, das ist so ein deutscher Neonazi, der sich da eingenistet hat, der genießt ja die Freedom of Speech, den kann man da weder rechtlich belangen, noch verhaften lassen. Was der da tut, ist seine verfassungsmäßig garantierten Rechte wahrnehmen. Und ja, aus ist so. Und dann kann man in Deutschland den Kram abrufen. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie gehen wir damit um? Wollen wir jetzt alle Service Provider erschießen? Oder wollen wir vielleicht den Kindern hier beibringen, dass es eben Nazi-Propaganda gibt und dass man entsprechend irgendwie damit umgehen muss?
Und gab es in den letzten Wochen und Monaten diverse Beispiele, nicht nur von Verletzungen sozusagen, also wenn man das jetzt mal aus der Warte betrachtet, was konkret im Internet zugänglich ist, gibt es ja diverse Angebote an verschiedenen Stellen des Netzes, die ganz konkret deutsche Gesetzgebungen streifen, die allerdings mit den Gesetzgebungen in den Ländern, wo sie veröffentlicht werden, also an der Stelle, wo sozusagen die Daten in das Internet gehen, durchaus vereinbar sind. Eins hatten wir ja schon genannt, radikal. Das zweite ist die Zündelpages. Gibt es noch weitere Beispiele?
Naja, es gibt wohl eine ganze Reihe von Beispielen, aber ich denke, wir konzentrieren uns hier auf ein paar Fälle, wo man sozusagen deutlich die Position sehen kann. Und der wohl krasseste Fall hat sich gerade erst zugetragen, ich glaube am Wochenende oder am Freitag oder wann war es? Das war am Freitag in Österreich. Da haben wir gleich am Telefon nach den Nachrichten dann jemanden vom betroffenen Internet Service Provider. Da ist also, weil ein Jahr vorher von dem Server aus angeblich ein kinderpornografisches Bild ins Netz irgendwie eingespielt wurde, auf welchen Testgrundweg zugänglich war. Und das Allerschönste daran ist, dass die Anzeige nicht etwa aus Österreich selbst kommt, sondern die kommt von der Staatsanwaltschaft in München, weil da irgendwelche, wie nennt man die Blockwarte oder was gab es da für eine Bezahlung? Digitale Blockwarte. Irgendwelche digitalen Blockwarte, also Polizisten, die im Netz patrouillieren. Vor einem Jahr, da irgendwo auf ein Bild gestoßen sind, und was dann passiert ist, wird uns gleich geschildert, da ist also gleich alles mitgenommen worden. Und also in der Extremform hat sich das selbst in Deutschland noch nicht zugetragen. Wir hatten ja diesen Fall der Staatsanwaltschaft München, die bei CompuServe in München im letzten Jahr war, und die haben dann immerhin noch gesagt, naja gut, irgendwie können wir hier nicht alles mitnehmen.
Wir werden nach dem Fritz Kurz Info dann mit Michael Herrmann sprechen, von diesem betroffenen Internet Service Provider in Österreich.
In Wien, genau.
Der heißt VIP in Wien. Und dann werden wir immer konkret dazu befragen, was dort eigentlich vorgefallen ist. Was wir ganz vergessen haben zu sagen, ist, dass leider wir heute keine Mail lesen können aus technischen Problemen. Wir sind natürlich nach wie vor aufgeschlossen für Post von Euch unter der E-Mail-Adresse chaos.orb.de. Der IRC-Channel allerdings Chaosradio ist offen. Der Andreas sitzt dort und kann Euch weitere Fragen zu dem aktuellen Thema oder auch anderen Themas gerne beantworten. So, am Telefon haben wir jetzt Michael Herrmann von dem vorhin geschilderten Pfeil betroffenen Internet-Service Provider in Österreich VIP. Hallo Michael.
Vielleicht sagst Du uns kurz zunächst einmal, wer Ihr seid, was Ihr nochmal macht und was da irgendwie sich bei Euch zugetragen hat in den letzten Tagen oder genau genommen wohl am 20.
Ja, also wir sind die Firma VIP. Wir sind ein Internet-Service Provider, so wie es auch einige andere gibt natürlich. Wir haben insgesamt sechs Filialen in Österreich und versuchen unseren Kunden, da sind also ungefähr 40% gewerbliche Kunden und 60% Privatkunden, nach Möglichkeit seriöse Internetdienste anzubieten.
Und was ist da bei euch passiert am 20. am Freitag?
Nein, das war Donnerstags. Ich war mit meinem Geschäftspartner gerade bei einer Firma, als eine unserer Mitarbeiterinnen ganz aufgeregt anrief, dass Beamte der Polizei bei uns wären, die unsere Anlage demontieren. Wir waren nicht weit entfernt, Gott sei Dank, sprangen also ins Auto und waren wenige Minuten später bei uns in der Firma. Da waren schon zum Teil die Computer in Autos verladen, alles abgeschaltet, die Stecker herausgezogen, etc.
Das ging überfallskommandoartig ab?
Ja, sozusagen. Als wir fragten, was Sache sei, wurde uns ein Ausdurchsuchungsbefehl gezeigt, der den Auftrag hatte, alle zur Beweissicherung dienenden Festplatten zu beflagnahmen.
Was ist denn der genaue Vorwurf, der euch als Internet-Service-Provider gemacht wird und vor allem, wie lange ist das her, was euch da vorgeworfen wird?
Ja, also es ist so uns direkt als Provider wird eigentlich nicht vorgeworfen. Also wir sind nicht die Beschuldigten. Laut dem Hausdurchsuchungsbefehl hat ein Kunde von uns am 10. März 1996 kinderpornografisches Material über unsere Anlage ins Internet eingespielt. Es steht nicht in welcher Form, wir vermuten halt mal sehr stark, dass es um einen Newsclub ging.
Also vor rund einem Jahr und wieso wird dann bei euch alles mitgenommen und was droht euch jetzt als diejenigen, die da einfach nur als technische Instanz irgendwo dazwischen sind?
Ja, das ist eben das Problem, dass es keine Präzedenzfälle gibt. Das heißt, ich nehme an, dass an uns sozusagen die Sache jetzt ausjudiziert wird und das Ergebnis ist natürlich in jeder Weise irgendwie offen.
Und ihr seid jetzt tatsächlich bedroht in eurer geschäftlichen Existenz durch diese Beschlagnahme, oder?
Ja, es ist natürlich so, dass wir im Moment, also dass wir dann relativ schnell aufgrund der großen Hilfestellungen, die wir von anderen bekommen haben, eine Notanlage mal in Betrieb nehmen konnten und momentan sind wir also dabei, den Notbetrieb sozusagen zu erweitern in einen, kann man schon sagen, ähnlichen Vollbetrieb.
Aber jetzt nochmal zu diesem Fall. Wie geht ihr denn jetzt damit um? Weil wenn ihr nicht mal beschuldigt seid, sondern nur, ich weiß ja nicht, wie sich das im österreichischen Gesetze nennt, was ihr überhaupt seid, wie geht ihr denn jetzt damit um? Wenn euch denn da irgendwie alles mitgenommen wird? Und ich meine, die hätten, die Polizisten hätten ja auch danach fragen können, wer war das? Können wir denjenigen ausfindig machen? Sind Dokumente vielleicht aufzeichnend vorhanden? Elektronische Aufzeichnungen? Ich meine, die haben ja alles mitgenommen. Die haben euch ja nicht jetzt irgendwie gefragt, wer war der Schuldige oder irgendwie so in der Art?
Ja, also laut unseren Rechtsanwälten ist an und für sich die Beschlagnahme, so wie sie vorgenommen wurde, mit etlichen Rechtsmängeln behaftet, sagen wir mal so. Das heißt, wir hätten zuerst aufgefordert werden müssen, die entsprechenden Daten herauszugeben. Man hätte uns vorher vernehmen müssen. Auf das kann nur verzichtet werden, wenn Gefahr in Verzug ist. Das kann man aber nach einem Jahr wirklich nicht mehr behaupten, dass Gefahr in Verzug ist. Das heißt, so wie es abgelaufen ist, war es also sicher mit einigen, sag ich mal, Pannen behaftet.
Und wie ist jetzt euer konkreter Umgang damit? Wie geht ihr jetzt mit diesem Ermittlungsverfahren um? Und vor allem, wie gehen die anderen Internetprovider in Österreich als Reaktion auf diesen Fall um? Man hat ja von einem Streik gehört. Was ist denn da sozusagen in Folge passiert?
Es ist also so, wir können derweil eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht damit umgehen, was die Behörden anbelangt, weil die Rechner sind einfach weg. Wir haben zwar einen Teil der unwichtigeren Geräte wieder zurückbekommen. Der andere Teil ist noch in irgendeiner Sachverständigenuntersuchung. Befragt wurden wir bislang in keiner Weise. Das wird sich höchstwahrscheinlich alles erst in Zukunft weisen. Die Provider haben insofern reagiert, als dass am Wochenende eine große Providerversammlung stattgefand in Wien. Es ist so, es gibt einen in Gründung befindlichen Dachverband zu österreichischen Internetprovider, der nennt sich ISPA.
Ja, da haben wir nachher noch jemanden zu.
Ja, wunderbar. Und da wurde also dieses Thema sehr erörtert. Es ist halt eine sehr schwierige Materie. Ich weiß, dass die Provider in Deutschland auch damit zu kämpfen haben. Einerseits ist also die Aussage der Staatsanwaltschaft oder die Haltung der Staatsanwälte in Österreich so, dass sie der Meinung sind, wenn der Provider weiß, dass solches Material über seine Anlage läuft, dann ist er haftbar zu machen. Wenn er es nicht weiß, dann ist er sozusagen schuldlos. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was heißt wissen und was heißt nicht wissen. Es ist einfach bei der Menge an Daten, die über einen Internetprovider laufen, statistisch, praktisch hundertprozentig anzunehmen, dass irgendwelche illegale Inhalte, das muss ja nicht nur Kinderpornografie sein, das kann ja auch anderes sein, laufen. Ist das jetzt schon wissen oder nicht?
Also auf gut Deutsch, ihr seid da im Moment in einer völlig willkürlichen Rechtsauslegung der jeweiligen Staatsanwaltschaften irgendwie ausgeliefert. Und ja, ihr könnt da sozusagen erst mal nur reagieren. Aber sozusagen weitergehende Ideen von euch als Internet-Service-Provider, ich meine, wie geht er jetzt in Zukunft damit um?
Ja, die Sache ist so, also der Standpunkt derzeit sieht so aus, also auch im Zusammenarbeit mit den anderen Internet-Providern, die sich ja sehr solidarisch erklärt haben, ist die Sache so, dass wir den Behörden unsere Zusammenarbeit anbieten. Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir den Behörden grundsätzlich irgendwelche böse Absichten hier vorwerfen. Weil ich glaube, dass das einfach nur irgendwie aus einer gewissen Ungeficklichkeit herausgekommen ist. Diese ganze Aktion, weil man eben nicht weiß, mit diesen neuen Medien umzugehen.
Also ich bewundere auf jeden Fall eure positive Einstellungen, die ihr trotz allem zu staatlichen Organen behaltet.
An sich ist das Ansinnen, dass man Kinderpornografie oder Hersteller oder die Urheber die Kinderpornografisches Material herstellen und verbreiten. Also dass man denen habhaft wird. Das ist an sich ein ordentliches Ziel, dass auch die Internetprovider durchaus unterstützen.
Selbstverständlich.
Keine Frage, nicht?
Nee, nee klar.
In der Folge sag ich einmal, dass das Ziel der Behörden in dem Fall durchaus zu akzeptieren ist. Nur die Art und Weise, wie vorgegangen worden ist, ist aus Scherste zurückzuweisen und aus Scherste zu kritisieren. Und um es mal mit dem, weil immer so schöne blöde Gleichnisse gebracht werden, nicht? Es ist wie gesagt auch der Autobusfahrer nicht beantwortlich, wenn mal ein Drogenhändler in seinem Bus sitzt und mitfährt. Der kann auch nicht jeden seiner Fahrgäste kontrollieren. Das würde auch niemals jemand von ihm verlangen und deswegen würde auch niemand den Bus beschlagnahmen. In der Hinsicht ist sehr vieles schief gelaufen, das jetzt nicht misszuverstehen. Wie gesagt, um darauf zurückzukommen, was die Provider beschlossen haben. Die Provider haben beschlossen, eine Informationsstelle zu machen, wo Leute die illegale Inhalte entdecken, das melden können, sodass die Provider, so es in ihrem Einflussbereich liegt, darauf reagieren können.
Also eure Stellung dazu ist, dass ihr durchaus mit den Behörden zusammenarbeiten wollt?
Ja, durchaus. Es ist nämlich so eine Sache. Es ist ein sehr schwieriges Thema.
Wir kommen auch im Laufe der Sendung noch zu anderen Beispielen, wo wir sozusagen diese Rechtskonfrontation haben. Also ich möchte nochmal betonen, mich bewundert eure trotzdem positive Einstellungen zu der Intervention der Staatsanwaltschaften, weil in der Tat hier wurde ja der Bus erstmal beschlagen, ums anders auszusprechen, wurde sozusagen das Telefonnetz über den womöglich auch mal ein Krimineller telefoniert hat, erstmal abgeschaltet. Na klar, aber wir werden gleich noch den Pilz von der ISPA dazu haben, also da sozusagen auf die übergeordnete Irrungsschein. Und jetzt müssen unsere Hörer erstmal mit etwas Musik zwischendurch erfreuen. Vielen Dank erstmal nach Österreich.
Hier ist Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Radio Fritz. Unser Thema Kontrolle elektronischer Medien, vor allem das Internet und die Zensurdebatte. Wir haben jetzt am Telefon Michael Pilz vom ISPA. Das ist der Verband der Internet Service Provider in Österreich. Wir haben ja eben schon mit dem Michael Herrmann gesprochen, von dem WIP, von dem betroffenen Internet Service Provider. Die ISPA ist jetzt eine neu gegründete Organisation. Andi?
Genau, vielleicht stellst Du Dich, Entschuldigung, vielleicht stellen Sie sich noch mal kurz selbst vor, was die ISPA ist, was ist denn die Zielsetzung dieses Vereins und was sind jetzt natürlich die ganz konkreten Reaktionen der ISPA auf diesen Fall, der sich da zugetragen hat?
Sehr gerne. Ich bin Vertreter der ISPA, das heißt ich bin Rechtsanwalt. Die ISPA ist ein Zusammenschluss von Internet-Providern, praktisch allen Internet-Providern in Österreich, die sie jetzt gegründet hat. Die Gründung war schon vor einem Gespräch, aber ein konkreter Anlasspunkt der zu einer raschen Gründung des Verbandes geführt hat, war die Beflagnahme in den Räumlichkeiten der VEP. Zielsetzung der ISPA ist ein gemeinsames Vorgehen aller Provider, gerade gegenüber den jetzt laufenden Bestrebungen, das Internet in rechtliche Rahmen zu gießen, bzw. die Zensurdebatte im Internet zu beginnen, um hier eine gemeinsame Linie zu machen und zu sagen, wir als Provider wollen das, wir können das, wir wollen das nicht, und wir wollen dafür bestimmte Rahmenbedingungen haben.
Ich meine, das klingt fast so, als sei das sozusagen förderlich gewesen, dass die Ermittlungsbehörden durchgeknallt sind. Natürlich. Na klar, gibt es schon eine Zielsetzung, die sich der Verband jetzt im Namen der Provider gegeben hat, was jetzt also konkret die Bestrebungen betrifft, da irgendwo Informationsfreiheit vielleicht durchzusetzen bzw. solche Verfahren abzuwehren?
Also die Provider sind im Augenblick in Österreich die Situation, dass theoretisch jeden Tag wieder irgendwo eine Hausdurchsuchung, eine Beschlagnahme von Geräten stattfinden könnte. Was aus der VEP passiert ist, kann jedem anderen Provider, jedem kleinen, jedem großen auch passieren. So kann man natürlich nicht wirtschaftlich arbeiten, das ist absolut unsinnig, so kann man das Internet auch nicht ausweiten. Die Provider möchten jetzt, und haben das auch schon angekündigt, mit der Bundesregierung in Kontakt treten, sagen, wir möchten hier eine klare gesetzliche Regelung, damit wir wissen, wo beginnt unsere Verantwortung und wo endet sie. Wir sagen auch ganz klar, sie endet jedenfalls dort, wo es um Inhalte geht, die von den Provider nicht selbst gestaltet werden. Wenn Provider als Pro 6S Provider auftreten, kann sie keine Verantwortung treffen.
Klar, und das heißt, dass sozusagen euer zunächst einmal, also mich würden jetzt sozusagen zwei Ebenen interessieren. Die eine ist die ganz konkrete, was macht ihr jetzt in diesem Fall? Wie erklärt ihr jetzt den Internet, Entschuldigung, den Ermittlungsbehörden, dass es irgendwie nicht angehen kann, da einen ganzen Internet Service Provider zu verhaften? Und die nächste Frage wäre natürlich, wie geht ihr in Zukunft mit den Ermittlungsbehörden um? Weil bevor es da irgendwelche Gesetze gibt, wird es ja, denke ich, noch eine Weile dauern, wie das so ist.
Also das eine ist, wir stehen in Österreich vor der lustigen Situation, dass die gesamte Justizverwaltung einen Zugang zum Internet hat. Also alle Gerichte...
Also einen Account wahrscheinlich?
Einen Account, richtig. Einen Computer, wo sie reinschauen können. Das ist natürlich absurd. Das heißt, wir müssen als Allererstes den Gerichten erklären, was ist das eigentlich?
Ist das dann eure Aufgabe?
Das ist leider unsere Aufgabe. Nämlich dann, wenn wir feststellen müssen, wenn wir diese Aufgabe nicht wahrnehmen, werden uns die Geräte unterm Sitz weggezogen. Dann müssten wir das leider tun. Also wir mit Angeboten den Gerichten, wir erklären euch, dass wir gehen auch jetzt hin zum Landesgericht für Strafsachen in Wien sagen, das ist so und so. Das sind die Rahmenbedingungen, so funktioniert das. Was heißt das überhaupt, wenn Newsgroups irgendwo liegen? Wie schaut es aus mit dem Newsfeed? Wer bringt welchen Inhalt ein? Und um welche Datenmenge handelt es sich hier überhaupt, die von einem Provider allenfalls überblickt werden könnte oder überblickt werden müsste? Wir machen es ganz konkret im Verfahren. Im Verfahren ist ein Antrag auf Herausgabe der Computer gestellt worden. Diesen Antrag hat die Untersuchungsrichterin nicht beitreten wollen. Sie hat das jetzt an die Ratskammer im Landesgericht abgetreten, die das zu entscheiden hat. Die Ratskammer wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr diese Woche entscheiden. Das heißt, es ist abzusehen, dass mindestens noch weitere 10 bis 14 Tage die Computer beschlagnahmt bleiben.
Das ist ja erstmal die juristische Ebene. Jetzt gab es ja ganz konkret diese Protestaktion. Ich weiß nicht, ob die von Ihrem Verband jetzt initiiert wurde oder wie das abgelaufen ist.
Wir wurden vom ISBA initiiert. Das heißt, es gab letztes Wochenende eine überraschend und kurzfristig einberufene Sitzung aller Providern, die zumindest alle, die in Wien ansässig waren, teilgenommen haben. Die anderen waren über E-Mail mit der Sitzung verbunden, wo der gemeinsame Beschluss von 90 Prozent aller österreichischen Providern getroffen wurde. Wir machen einen Streik. Zwei Stunden lang geht Österreich offline. Dieser Streik hat stattgefunden. Dienstag, von 16 bis 18 Uhr, war Österreich praktisch lahmgelegt. Bis auf zwei Provider, die wirklich sich aus inhaltlichen Gründen nicht beteiligen wollten, haben alle anderen mitgemacht. Und das hat große Aufregungen verursacht.
Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen als letzte abschließende Frage euer Blick in die Zukunft? Geht ihr mit eigenen Vorstellungen der Verantwortung oder von dem, was im Netz möglich sein soll, was es an Freiheiten bieten soll oder vielleicht auch an Einschränkungen der Freiheit in die Diskussion? Oder seid ihr da im Grunde genommen ein bisschen eher auf der Ebene, dass ihr euch jetzt anhört, was die Ermittlungsbehörden oder der Gesetzgeber sagt und dann sozusagen euch diesen Strukturen ein bisschen anpasst?
Nein, ganz und gar nicht. Wir gehen hier in die Offensive. Wir sagen, wir haben jeden Tag mit dem Medium zu tun. Wir wissen am ehesten, was hier läuft. Wir sagen einerseits, die österreichischen Provider sind der Auffassung, dass Kinderpornografie und Neonazi im Netz an sich nicht verloren hat. Wir wehren uns gegen diese Inhalte aus inhaltlichen Gründen. Das ist die Position der Provider. Wir wollen mit dem Schmuddelkram auch nichts zu tun haben, weil es dazu immer wieder in der öffentlichen Diskussion hergenommen wird, die wichtigen und guten und demokratischen und basisdemokratischen Seiten des Internets auch in den Dreck zu ziehen. Das ist die Position 1. Position 2. Wir haben jetzt schon vereinbart Gesprächstermine mit dem Justizministerium, mit dem Innenministerium und mit den politischen Parteien, wo wir unsere Vorstellungen darlegen wollen. Die lauten, dem Provider trifft keine Haftung, wenn er von dem Inhalt nichts wusste. Wenn er positive Kenntnisse hatte, dann trifft ihn Haftung. Die Provider sind bereit, bei der Aufklärung von strafbaren Handlungen insofern mitzuwirken, als sie, wenn über richterlichen Befehl die Herausgabe bestimmter Daten vorgesehen wird, diese Daten natürlich herausgeben werden.
Aber vielleicht nicht gleich die Computer mitnehmen?
Das heißt nicht gleich die Computer mitnehmen. Das heißt insbesondere nur jene Daten, die wirklich relevant sind. Ich kann die Computer mit den Mails von anderen tausenden Usern mitnehmen. Ich muss daher differenzieren. Und ich muss natürlich Fernmeldegeheimnisse, Datengeheimnisse, analog das Briefgeheimnis im Internet wahren. Dafür brauche ich prozessuale und materiell rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen.
Na dann wünschen wir Euch zunächst einmal viel Glück bei der Aufklärung Eurer staatlichen Organe. Und bedanken uns für das Gespräch.
Tja, es geht heiß her in Österreich. Habe ich so den Eindruck?
Na die haben echt Spaß, aber wer weiß, vielleicht kriegen sie es ihren Ermittlungsberatern ja echt erkehrt.
Der Ansatz ist natürlich irgendwie so ein bisschen anders als in Deutschland.
Naja, das würde ich nicht sagen. Wir sind ja auch hier dabei, den Polizkanzler. Ich bin ja auch in Bonn und erkläre Ihnen da, wie das ist mit den Bits, die von Computer zu Computer fliegen. Ach nee, das war irgendwie anders. Mach doch mal Musik an.
Hier ist Chaosradio und wir sind dabei mit Zensur im Internet. Wir haben noch zwei Telefonintervüß für euch in Vorbereitung. Das kommt nachher.
Kurzmeldungen.
Tja, an dieser Stelle sollten eigentlich die Chaos Kurzmeldungen folgen. Nur leider sind die einem Hahn aus Reppenmund, nämlich haben Bill Gates zum Opfer gefallen. Ich hab mir da eine Stunde lang die Finger wund getippt an den Chaos Kurzmeldungen. Und beim Speichern blieb die Maus stehen und die Kiste tat halt nicht. Ein hervorragend konfigurierter Windows PC, aber leider ging's halt nicht.
Und deswegen, bilden wir jetzt das nächste Lied unserem geliebten Freund Bill Gates. Nein, unserem momentan anvisierten Feindbild.
Nein, unser geliebter Freund Bill Gates will für dich ein Lied.
Ja, und jetzt gleich, haben wir ja am Telefon jetzt schon, aber der wird jetzt mal einen Moment ruhig sein. Den Rob Conkrib vom holländischen Service Provider, Internet Service Provider Access for All, das ist nebenbei der größte dort mittlerweile. Access for All ist hervorgegangen aus Hektik, aus sozusagen dem Analogung des Chaos Computer Clubs in den Niederlanden. Die hatten da auch eine eigene Zeitschrift, wie wir hier die Datenschleuder. Und haben dann irgendwann zunächst einmal die digitale Stadt gemacht, so ein Stadtinformationssystem, wo man sozusagen Menschen verständlich drin herwandeln könnte. Also dort hieß E-Mail zwar auch E-Mail, aber dorthin ging man mit der Assoziation Ich will zum Postamt oder Zeitschriften gab es am Chaos. Also das war alles auf eine Ebene um sozusagen Menschen, die nicht diese technische Umgebung gewohnt sind, sondern die Umgebung einer ganz normalen Stadt, da den Zugang zu ermöglichen. Und daraus ist dann irgendwann Access for All hervorgegangen. Und die haben schon so in den letzten Jahren, würde ich sagen, einiges an Spaß gehabt mit Ermittlungsbehörden und anderen. Da kam zum Beispiel irgendwann die Sekte Scientology auf die Idee, den Service World Wide Access for All komplett zu verhaften, mehr oder weniger, weil eben geheime sekteninterne Materialien, wie sie zugänglich gemacht waren. Das ist eine ganz lange Geschichte, auf die wir jetzt nicht so viel eingehen wollen. Aber letztendlich kann man sagen, hat Scientology es nicht verhaftet und auch nicht geschafft, diese Materialien nicht zugänglich zu machen, weil natürlich international sich alle dagegen verschworen haben. Und das war auch ganz prima, weil da hatte das Internet endlich ein gemeinsames Feindbild. Das verbindet ja immer ungemein, wie wir auch eben bei den Österreichern gehört haben. Heute wollen wir reden über die Zeitschrift Radikal. Die Zeitschrift Radikal ist eigentlich eine deutsche, aber wird irgendwie in den Niederlanden verlegt, ist da nämlich legal. Und Rob, vielleicht als allererster Frage, was habt Ihr als Provider eigentlich mit der Radikal zu tun? Oder wann habt Ihr zuerst davon gehört, dass Ihr irgendwie mit der Radikal vielleicht ein Problem habt?
Wir haben eigentlich ganz wenig oder nichts mit Radikal zu tun. Einer unserer Benutzer, und wir haben im Moment 20.000 von solchen Benutzer, einer unserer Benutzer hat Radikal, ich glaube Ausgabe 154 auf seine Homepage gesetzt. Also er hat selber die Radikal Textfile und auch einige Graphics zu unserer Maschine heruntergeladen und gesagt, das ist eine Homepage. Wir haben davon mitbekommen, weil wir von deutschen Staatsanwaltschaften, nein wir haben von Internet Content Task Force, das ist so eine Gruppe von Provider.
Das ist eine deutsche Provider Vereinigung, die sich im Sinne des vorauseilenden Gehorsamens manchmal den Problem widmet. Ihr habt als erstes davon mitbekommen, dass ihr von der ICTF angesprochen wurdet oder dass euer Server direkt von deutschen Service Provider nicht mehr abrufbar war. Was hat da zuerst angefangen?
Wir haben zuerst mal vom Internet Content Task Force gehört und die haben den deutschen Provider aufgerufen Access for All unerreichbar zu machen. Weil wir gesagt haben, dass es unserer Einsicht nach kein holländisches Straftat vorlag. Und dann haben ganz viele deutsche Presse uns angerufen und dann war Radikal auch ganz bekannt. Gleich am ersten Tag haben Leute angefangen Radikal mehr rauszumachen, in der ganzen Welt. Radikal würde überall in der Welt kopiert als Protest gegen diese Aktion. Dann war Access for All vor vier, fünf Tagen von Deutschland aus schlecht erreichbar. Also Homepage ist von Access for All Ministerin schlecht aufrufbar.
Da kommen wir später noch sozusagen zu. Was mich noch mal interessieren würde, ist, was ist denn die Rechtslage, in der ihr euch da bewegt? Wir haben ja schon gehört, die Radikal ist in Holland völlig legal, die kann man auch am Bahnhofsgiers kaufen. Wie ist denn die Rechtslage der Internet Service Provider? Habt ihr da schon akute Gesetze oder habt ihr da schon sozusagen dauernde Probleme mit Ermittlungsbehörden oder ist das eigentlich alles ganz entspannt bei euch? Weil das war jetzt auch kein direktes juristisches Verfahren, zumindest von holländischer Seite gegen euch, sondern von deutscher Seite. Und die Auswirkungen waren ja auch technischer und nicht juristischer Natur. Ist das sonst bei euch entspannt oder wie geht es da ab?
Während der Scientology-Krise ist schon vom Politiker heraus gesagt worden, dass eigentlich Internet-Service-Provider nicht angesprochen werden können auf die Content von Webpages und so weiter, solange sie davon nicht wissen oder solange es irgendeinen Benutzer gibt, die man nachspüren kann, die das auf die Server gestellt hat.
Also es ist kein akutes Problem, kann man sagen.
Naja, es wird also gesagt, dass nur wenn es keinen nachspurbaren User gibt, die seine Homepage damit aufgemacht hat, dann ist vielleicht den Provider Ansprechpunkt für juristische Sachen.
Der Generalbundesanwalt hier, der Deutsche, der Herr Nehm heißt er glaube ich, der hat ja mal bekannt gegeben, dass sozusagen der Herausgeber oder der Geschäftsführer von Access for All, das ist der Philipp glaube ich, sozusagen durchaus strafrechtlich belangt werden könne, wenn er dann zum Beispiel mal durch Deutschland reist. Er hat also sozusagen implizit angekündigt, dass er ihn verhaften lassen würde, wenn er mal durch Deutschland irgendwie durchreist. Weil wie gesagt, nach deutschem Recht ja diese radikale Strafwass und derjenige, der sie zugänglich macht, sich irgendwie auch straffarmacht. Wie geht ihr denn damit um oder wie geht Philipp damit um? Reist er jetzt nicht mehr nach Deutschland?
Der hat schon zwei, drei Mal nach Deutschland gereist und ist nicht verhaftet worden. Aber vielleicht kommt das noch. Aber die Bundesanwaltschaft ist in dieser Sache völlig doof, weil die versuchen sogar ein deutsches Parlamentsmitglied, die auf ihrer Homepage eine Verweisung zu dieser Seite, die bei Access for All steht, die Seite von unserer Benutzer. Das Parlamentsmitglied macht eine Verweisung dahin und das versuchen sie sogar als Straftat zu benennen. Also die sind wirklich doof.
Also die drehen sozusagen durch. Und na gut, das denke ich war eine prägnante Zusammenfassung. Als letzte Frage vielleicht noch, hast du sozusagen für die Zukunft gesprochen, jetzt Befürchtung, das was ich durch diese europäischen Gesetzgebungen, die noch später an unserer Sendung hier besprochen werden, also dieses PIX-System und diese ganzen Geschichten, dass sich da was ändert, dass sozusagen dieser eher entspannte Umgang mit Holland irgendwie da in problematische Zeiten gerät? Oder glaubst du, das ist erstmal da nicht so ein Problem behauptet in der Zukunft für euch?
Ja, ich glaube es ist ganz schwierig zu sagen, in welchen Richtungen die ganze europäische Gesetze, nicht nur für Internet-Content, aber für alles, wohin die sich bewegen. Und das ist also ein ganz großes demokratisches Problem, was das nicht nur im Bereich vom Internet spielt.
Ein großes Wort gelassen ausgesprochen. Ok, jetzt sage ich erstmal vielen Dank für das späte Abend-Interview und wir machen mal weiter hier. Tschüss.
Vielleicht noch anzumerken, es gab denn auch Demonstrationen von autonomen Transparenten mit der URL von der Radikale, die dann halt da rumgetragen wurden.
www.accessforallathome, irgendwas. Ok, wir werden uns dann da grüßen.
Und vielleicht noch kurz bevor wir dann zu der Musik umdrehen, noch eine Geschichte, die Rob angeführt hat. Es ist also so, dass die Angela Mark war, die, ich glaube, stellvertretende Vorsitzende der PDS oder irgendwie so eine Position hat sie, ihrerseits eine Homepage, also eine eigene Seite im BWW hatte, die sie gestaltet hat, und da hatte sie einen Link eben drauf, also ein automatisch anklickbares Dings, wo man eben, wenn man da draufklickt, dann wiederum bei Access for All auf dem Server dort landet und radikal abrufen kann. Und ihr wurde jetzt von der irgendwie General Dingsda Anwaltschaft Berlin ein Ermittlungsverfahren und das Staatsanwaltschaft und der Prozess ist auch schon eröffnet, wo sie jetzt also angeklagt ist, sie würde das irgendwie zugänglich machen oder was auch immer. Also Rob hat das glaube ich schon präzise zu formulieren.
Das heißt, wenn man also heute einem Holländer oder einem irgendeinen Menschen auf der Welt erzählt, dass er ein bestimmtes Buch, das in Deutschland oder sonst wo vielleicht wird, das muss nicht sein, oder?
Ich wollte auch mal den telegenden Kommentar abgeben.
Das macht man mit der Musik.
Wenn man also heute jemanden erzählt, dass ein Buch irgendwo in Alexandria in der Bibliothek steht, dann ist das schon strafbar womöglich.
Naja, jeder, der auf einen Drogen-Diener zeigt, kommt sozusagen auch gleich bitte den Knast. Die Homepage von Angela Marquardt und auch die ganzen anderen angesprochenen URLs, einschließlich der URL, die ihr radikal zeigt, werdet ihr natürlich erhalten über den Chaosradioticker, so ihr euch dort eingetragen habt.
Das ist mir nicht illegal.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal mit unserer Rechtsabteilung sprechen.
Lass mir dann doch besser mal drauf ankommen. Wer dort noch nicht eingetragen ist, wer also noch nicht einer von Stand heute 292 Eingetragenen auf den Chaosradioticker ist, der klicke sich mal durch zu www.ccc.de slash chaosradio oder überhaupt mal durch die Homepage des CCC durchklicken. Da hat sich einiges hinzugefügt. Ihr könnt euch auf die Mailinglist eintragen lassen und dann bekommt ihr immer Vorankündigungen für die nächste Sendung und ihr bekommt auch eine Ergebnissammlung von unserer aktuellen Sendung.
Jetzt bekommt ihr Musik. Bevor wir jetzt gleich den nächsten Gesprächspartner rannehmen, noch mal ganz kurz die Geschichte vollständig. Was war passiert? Die Bundesanwaltschaft hat ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen die Radikale irgendwie am Laufen schon längere Zeit und dann haben sie irgendwie mitbekommen, dass die also im Internet verfügbar ist. Und da sie sich des holländischen Service-Providers Access for All, ob das ein Server die lag, wo wir den Rob eben am Telefon hatten, nicht haphaf werden konnten, weil wir gesagt haben, das ist völlig legal und außerdem ist der im Ausland und den kann man auch weder verhaft noch erschießen lassen, haben sie sich an die gewarnt, die irgendwie hier rumlaufen und das sind die deutschen Internet-Service-Providers. Nun, es ist natürlich viel zu mühselig für so eine Generalbundesanwaltschaft, die alle ausfindig zu machen und deswegen haben sie geguckt, gibt es da nicht irgendwie eine Vereinigung, einen Verband, an dem man sich wenden kann und haben auch einen gefunden. Das war in diesem Fall die ICTF. Die ICTF ist die sogenannte Internet Content Task Force, also schon ein ganz grausamer Titel. Das ist sozusagen eine Untervereinigung des ECO, des Electronic Commerce Forums, warum das auch immer ECO heißt, die sich zur Aufgabe gemacht hat, ja was denn eigentlich? Gut, das werden wir jetzt hier nicht klären können. Fakt ist, was passiert ist, ist, dass die Bundesanwaltschaft, die Generalbundesanwaltschaft, dem Michael Schneider vom ICTF, also auch schriftlich mitgeteilt hat, dass derjenige, der den technischen Zugang zur Zeitschrift radikal bietet, dass wir in diesem Fall zum Beispiel ein deutscher Internet-Service-Provider sich möglicherweise der Beihilfe zu einer Straftat, nämlich Aufforderung zu Straftaten und so sofort, ja strafbar macht. Die Geschichte ist, die Staatsanwaltschaft kann ja nicht sagen, was ist illegal, sondern illegal kann immer nur der Richter feststellen. Also was denn jetzt tatsächlich strafbar war. Und die Formulierung lautete eben möglicherweise strafbar. Und was der ICTF, der Herr Schneider, der Anwalt der ICTF dann gemacht hat, ist, er hat das allen Providerinnen und Provider geschrieben, hat ihnen also empfohlen, den solenischen Server Access for All technisch nicht mehr zugänglich zu machen, wegen eben der möglichen Beihilfe zur Aufruf zum Straftaten und so fort. Und die Service Provider selbst, die dann sozusagen dem Endkunden letztendlich, zum Beispiel hier in Berlin, uns hier das Internet bieten, die hatten dann da erst mal mit umzugehen, weil sozusagen ihre Leitung, wo sie sie haben, schon gesperrt war. Und genau dazu haben wir jetzt den Robert Rote, hier vom Berliner Service Provider Interactive Network von SNAPU. Wie seid ihr denn damit umgegangen? Was ist denn da sozusagen euch passiert?
Ja, hallo erstmal. Wir haben zunächst mal nur am Rande davon mitbekommen. Also wir haben beispielsweise das Schreiben des Herrn Schneider nicht bekommen. Wir haben eben das Glück, dass wir über mehrere Außenleitungen verfügen. Und so hat sich diese Sperrung von einem, beispielsweise unser Zulieferer, eben nicht so bemerkbar gemacht.
Also das heißt, auf einigen von euren Leitungen konntet ihr sozusagen Excess for All nicht mehr erreichen und musstet dann auf andere Leitungen ausweichen? Oder habt ihr das einfach so gemacht?
Exakt.
Und wie hältst du das sozusagen? Jetzt kann man ja sozusagen Verständnis oder Nicht-Verständnis dafür haben oder Angst oder Nicht-davor haben, dass man sich möglicherweise der Beihilfe zu Straftaten tätig macht. Was für eine Position würdest du denn als Internet Service Provider da formulieren, wie man mit solchen staatlichen Bestrebungen, Recht und Ordnung einzuhalten oder so ähnlich umgeht? Was tut man da sozusagen? Die Radikale ist vielleicht auch nicht das gute Beispiel. Da gibt es ja auch andere.
Zunächst mal würde ich denken, dass für einen solchen Beschluss zunächst mal ein Richter und nicht die Staatsanwaltschaft zuständig ist. Darüber hinaus ist es halt so, dass das Internet mit zunehmender Popularität, das heißt auch mit einem breiteren Nutzer Schicht sicher auch für den Staat interessant wird. Das heißt insofern interessant wird, als das Internet natürlich auch kein rechtsfreier Raum ist, wie das Leben da draußen auch in gesetzmäßigen Bahnen läuft.
Also du meinst so dieses richtige echte Leben?
Das ist genau das echte Leben. Und insofern diese Handlung zunächst mal nachvollziehbar ist. Dass sie aufgrund der Struktur dieses Netzes nicht besonders effektiv ist. Das heißt, dass man den Inhalt dieser Radikale, beispielsweise auch aufgrund der unterschiedlichen Gesetzgebungen in den verschiedenen Ländern nicht haper werden kann. Das ist eine ganz andere Frage und ein wesentlichen technisches Problem, was ich denke auch nicht so ohne weiteres gelöst werden kann. Ich war im Wesentlichen verwundert darüber, dass man sich nur ausgerechnet die Radikale ausgesucht hat, um die zu sperren. Ich denke mal nicht, dass ich die Radikale da größerer Leserkreise erfreut habe im Internet, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, bis man ihm offiziell verkündet hat, diese Seite müsste gesperrt werden.
Also gut, ich selbst habe im Bundestag mehr oder weniger die Debatte miterlebt, wo ich auch die Möglichkeit hatte zu sagen, im Grunde genommen sehe ich es auch so, dass die Bundesanwaltschaft diese Zeitschaft hier gefördert hat. Die hat eine Menge Werbung dafür gemacht.
Genau.
Klar, aber um noch mal ein bisschen mehr aufs Generelle zu kommen. Ich meine, Ihr als Internet-Service-Provider habt irgendwie eine bestimmte Rolle oder einen bestimmten Anspruch, Informationszuge, Freiheit, das Einspielen von Informationen zu beliefern. Und das, was der ECTF da macht als verbundeter Provider, als ich weiß nicht, selbst ernannt davon, das scheint mir dem noch ein bisschen entgegen zu laufen. Habt Ihr dann irgendein Verhältnis zu diesem ECTF?
Zunächst mal zum Grundsätzlichen. Das Internet besteht ja nicht nur aus dem World Wide Web, sondern aus einer ganzen Reihe von Diensten, die abgerufen werden können. Und insofern sind diese Dienste auch alle unterschiedlich zu behandeln. Beispielsweise, dass diese World Wide Web Geschichte eine Möglichkeit ist, zu sagen, man macht eine Adresse nicht erreichbar, was allerdings nicht dazu führt, dass zwangsläufig der Inhalt dieser Seite, die da irgendwann mal publiziert worden ist, nicht erreichbar ist. Das heißt, es ist quasi nur ein pro forma Handeln. Und gibt es andere Inhalte, wie beispielsweise Use-net-use, die nun lokal, oder meistens zumindest lokal, bei dem Provider gehalten werden oder gehalten werden sollen. Da ist es schon kritischer. Da gibt es beispielsweise Gruppen, die explizit beispielsweise zur Verbreitung der Darstellung von Kinderpornografie oder der Verbreitung von geknackter Software oder der gleichen Deam. Und da ist es nur so, dass das nach deutschem Recht auch für einen Nicht-Juristen einleuchtend ist, dass das irgendwie nach deutschem Recht nicht vereinbar ist. Und ich sag mal so, da sind wir natürlich auch auf die Mithilfe unserer Nutzer angewiesen, wie der eine Kollege da vom ISPA mitgeteilt hat. Die Datenmenge, die im Internet zur Verfügung steht und auch in den Newsenden, ist so gigantisch groß, dass man natürlich nicht alles sich angucken kann. Man kann quasi dort einen Sensor spielen. Oder sind wir auf die Mithilfe unserer Nutzer angewiesen, die uns da eben auf bestimmte Inhalte hinweisen? Was die ICTF angeht, da haben wir einen... Also wir sind Mitglied dieses EKOEV, aber ganz bewusst eben nicht Mitglied dieser ICTF. Weil unseres Erachtens ist zwar ein solcher Zusammenschluss und eine Interessenvertretung der deutschen Provinz sinnvoll und notwendig, doch in der Form, wie das von der ICTF gemacht wird, doch etwas kurios. Die sind immer noch einen Schritt weiter als Leute, die beispielsweise im Deutschen Bundestag das Medium Internet noch gar nicht verstanden haben. Und von ihrer Position aus dort...
Ich muss dich jetzt trotzdem noch unterbrechen, weil es läuft nur die Zeit weg, die wollen ja gleich die Nachricht machen. Es gibt jetzt eine ganze Menge geplante Gesetze und auch irgendwelche Auswirkungen. Hattest du jetzt schon konkrete Kontakte mit der Justiz? Vielleicht als auch Reaktion darauf, dass die Radikalie von euch abrufbar war und sozusagen euren Umgang damit. Habt ihr da schon Stress am Kommen?
Nein, zunächst mal gibt es ja eine ganze Reihe von Gesetzen, die gerade zur Debatte stehen bzw. bedauersicherweise schon verabschiedet worden sind. Ich kann die Namen jetzt nicht mehr genau auseinanderhalten, aber das...
Das machen wir nachher noch.
Gut, das letzte Gesetz ist meines Erachtens recht gelungen, wenn gleich eine Reihe von Gefahren wirkt. Das erste Gesetz, worauf ihr sicher nicht noch eingängig werdet, was die Überwachung und die, sei es mal nicht überschaubare Überwachung gestatten soll, das ist mir äußerst suspekt und ich weiß auch nicht, wie das technisch realisiert werden soll.
Aber jetzt ganz konkret ist bei dir da sozusagen, sind die Bemittlungsgehörn schon auf der Tür gestanden?
Ja, also wir weisen eben unseren Nutzer darauf hin, dass sie für den Inhalt verantwortlich sind, den sie ins Netz stellen. Das Internet ist eben anders als beispielsweise das Radio. Okay, wir telefonieren ja gerade und ich kann mich ja kundtun, aber das Internet ist eben nicht nur ein Dialogfähiges, sondern auch die Direktion als Medium. Das heißt, jeder Teilnehmer kann sich dort kundtun. Und wir weisen eben unseren Nutzer darauf hin, dass sie eben für die von ihnen verbreiteten Inhalte verantwortlich sind. Und ich glaube, da gab es sicherlich, oder gab es schon einige Fälle, wo dort einige gegen deutsche Gesetze verstoßen haben, ganz offenbar.
Na gut, okay, dann danken wir erstmal an diesen Eindruck und müssen jetzt leider hier überblenden, denn Nachrichtensprecher sucht schon das Mikro und den Platz. Und ich weiß nicht, ob noch Platz für Musik ist. Keiner weiß es, ich leite.
Doch, damit ist es 23 Uhr und 32 Minuten.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio im Blumen bei Radio Fritz. Unser Thema ist Kontrolle elektronischer Medien. Wir haben jetzt schon einige interessante Gespräche geführt mit betroffenen Internet-Service-Provider in Österreich und in Holland und in Deutschland. Jetzt haben wir auch genug telefoniert und wir werden uns nachher auch euch ein bisschen mehr zuwenden. Als Abschluss der Diskussion müssten wir jetzt wiederum noch mal darauf eingehen, welche konkreten Gesetze denn nun wirklich tatsächlich bereits verabschiedet sind oder beziehungsweise in Vorbereitung sind. Da ist ja einiges im Walde.
Also das Obermotto dieser Rubrik müsste eigentlich lauten, die Verirrung der menschlichen Zivilisation sind ihrer Gesamtheit unendlich und das schliegt sich ungefähr folgendermaßen wieder. Es gibt also zum einen den Herrn Rutgers, unseren Forschungsminister beim BMBF, der hat in Arbeit das EU-KDG, das Informations- und Kommunikationsdienste-Gesetz, enthalten darin ist auch die Signaturverordnung. Und das Gesetz soll eigentlich regeln, wer es wofür verantwortlich ist bei diesen neuen Diensten, um sozusagen klar zu sagen, hier haftet der Serviceprovider und hier nicht. Und nebenbei, diese Signaturverordnung ist angeblich eigentlich dazu da, um also rechtsverbindliche, elektronische Vertragsabschlüsse, Geschäftsabschlüsse und so fort zu machen. Das ist also das Gesetz mehr oder weniger fürs Internet, so wie er sich das vorstellt. Allerdings gibt es da noch ein kleines Problem, nämlich es gibt auch die Länder. Also auf der einen Seite hier den Bund, den Herrn Rutgers. Und die Länder haben dann den sogenannten Mediendienst, den Staatsvertrag ausgearbeitet, der im Grunde genommen, naja, was soll der eigentlich? Der soll sozusagen dasselbe tun, nur für andere Dienste. Das heißt, für zum Beispiel Video und Demand, für Verteildienste. Und da fängt es schon an, wenn man nämlich die gesetzlichen Definitionen sich anguckt und das, was wir in der Realität haben, zum Beispiel das Internet mit News, dann wissen weder die Juristen noch die Techniker noch irgendjemand im Moment, welches Gesetz dann eigentlich was regelt. Also ob zum Beispiel News unter das IOKDG des Bundes oder der Länder fallen. Und festzustellen bleibt, das IOKDG sollte neulich verabschiedet werden, ist im Bundesrat denn gescheitert, weil die SPD gesagt hat, das kann doch wohl nicht angehen. Erstmal muss klar sein, welches Gesetz überhaupt für welche technische Angelegenheit, die wir bereits haben, greifen soll.
Das IOKDG, vielleicht löst du das Akronym noch mal kurz auf. Das hatte ich doch schon.
und Kommunikationsdienst.
Informations-
Interessante Worte. Das ist vom Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung?
Genau.
Warum kümmert sich denn ausgerechnet dieses Ministerium um diesen Bereich?
Na ja, das ist eine echt blöde Frage, weil die Antwort ist so blöde. Der Herr Rütgers ist halt eines der innovativen Lieblingskinder von Kanzler Kohl und da muss ich irgendwie profilieren. Das heißt, im Grunde genommen müsste man fragen, wozu ist dieses Ministerium eigentlich da? Und dann wird man feststellen, irgendwie ist es eigentlich für was ganz anderes da, nämlich für Forschung und Technologie. Und das, was es hier tut, ist wirtschaftliche Belange regeln. Und warum es das tut, frag mich bitte nicht. Das hat mit dieser virtuellen Realität Bond zu tun, nämlich damit, dass der Rütgers irgendwie seine Position rechtfertigen muss. Aber es gibt noch viel Schlimmeres. Es gibt nämlich noch andere Sachen. Es gibt zum Beispiel das TKG, das Telekommunikationsgesetz. Das sind erstmal die noch darunter liegenden Sachen. Also zum Beispiel, wer jetzt als Konkurrenz zur Telekom ab nächsten Jahr da aktiv werden kann, regelt. Das heißt, da gibt es dann so interessante Gesetze wie zum Beispiel den § 90, der dann nicht nur sagt, also gut, die Leute können wie wer Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen für andere erbringen soll, dieses und jenes, und muss sich an diese Gesetze halten und dort die Leitung mieten. Sondern da steht er noch drin, dass er zum Beispiel staatlichen Behörden einen Zugang, einen Zugriff auf die Kundendaten jederzeit irgendwie anbieten muss. Und vor allem, dass er Abfragen dieser Kundendaten nicht feststellen darf. Also das heißt, er soll seine Kundendatenabrufer machen, aber er soll irgendwie das so machen, dass wenn da jemand reinhackt, dann soll er das auch nicht wissen.
Das TKG ist bereits verabschiedet?
Das TKG ist schon verabschiedet, aber das geht noch weiter, weil das TKG erlässt dann implizit durch Paragraphen noch sogenannte Verordnungen. Da gibt es zum Beispiel diese super schön, mein Lieblingsgesetz in diesem Zusammenhang, beziehungsweise mein Lieblingsverordnungsabschied.
Jetzt müsst ihr euch alle richtig festhalten.
Und jetzt bitte anschnallen. Das ist die Telekommunikations- und Informationsdienstleistungsunternehmens-Datenschutzverordnung. Die regelt, welche Daten jemand der Telekommunikations-Dienstleistungen für andere erbringt, speichern darf und welche nicht. Es gibt da eine Reihe richtig schrecklicher Gesetze. Auf der einen Seite kann man also feststellen, die deutsche Regulierungsvote hat zugeschlagen, alles muss in Beton gegossen werden und irgendwie mit links, rechts, oben und unten Schaltern versehen werden. Und da steht dann zum Beispiel drin, wer also im Verdacht steht, Telekommunikationsdienste zu missbrauchen. Bei dem dürfen auch, also bei Anschlüssen, die irgendwie missbraucht werden, da dürfen auch die Inhaltsdaten ausgewertet werden. Also nicht wie bisher nur die, wer ruft wen an, sondern auch was spricht er. Das heißt, da wird zu sagen, das Fernweiligesetzen, nebenbei irgendwie dieses Fernweiligeheimnis, wird irgendwie abgeschafft für zumindest Leute wie Hacker oder sowas. Das ist ja von vornherein...
Ganz konkret heißt das, die Telekom oder irgendein anderer Telekommunikationsanbieter darf legal mithören, allein wenn er schon nur den Verdacht hat. Und der ist immer begründbar.
Genau, und gut, da gibt es ja noch irgendwie Regelungen hier und Verordnungen da und Unterschrift hier. Aber es wird noch viel schlimmer. Nicht nur diese TEDSV, sondern dann haben wir noch eine Sache, die uns jetzt noch ins Haus steht, drohenderweise, die noch nicht verabschiedet ist, die es noch nicht mal im Entwurf öffentlich gibt und die es angeblich auch nie gehen soll, das ist das Krypto-Gesetz. Also die Regelung, Reglementierung oder Lizenzierung von Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die also womöglich so sicher sind, dass sie überhaupt keiner mehr mitlesen kann, außer demjenigen, der in der Schlüsselweite, also staatliche Stellen, können dann Kommunikationsströme nicht mehr verfolgen und entsprechend auch nicht einschränken.
An der Stelle müssen wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen ausholen und den Hintergrund auch klarzumachen, wovon wir reden. Bisher haben wir ja nur von... Aber vielleicht tun wir das nachher.
Hast du noch eine hübsche Gesetzes-Schmetterung? Die Sache ist ja die, wenn wir jetzt das mit dem Krypto-Gesetz schon machen und es ist schon 23.45 Uhr, dann kann unsere Hörer einfach nur noch vollgedröhnt mit Informationen.
Also fragen wir sie doch mal lieber selber. Wir würden gerne eure Meinung hören. Und zwar zu der Frage zum Thema zunächst einmal. Natürlich, wir sind immer gerne für qualifizierte Beiträge offen. Was ist also schlimmer? Zu viel Reglementierung oder zu viel Freiheit? Wenn Ihr dazu eine ausgeprägte Meinung habt, dann ruft uns bitte an. Unter Potsdam 0331 74 81 110.
Die Fritz Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110.
Hier ist Chaosradio. Wir wollen von Euch wissen, wie Ihr das seht mit der Zensur im Internet. Was ist schlimmer? Zu viel Reglementierung oder zu viel Freiheit? Ruft uns an unter 0331 74 81 110. Und anfangen tun wir mit Martin. Martin, hallo.
Hallo.
Du hast eine Meinung zu dem Thema. Bist du für mehr Reglementierung oder bist du für mehr Freiheit auf dem Internet?
Auf jeden Fall mehr Freiheit. Also eigentlich ist das ja gar nicht so eingeschränkt im Moment. Hoffentlich bleibt es auch so lange noch. Ein anderes Problem ist eigentlich, dass wenn man heute mal die Situation gerade jetzt im Moment in Berlin betrachtet, wo ja im Rathaus Schönebergs gebrannt hat heute Nachmittag, und jetzt das Internet, zumindest die ganzen Hochschweinrichtungen, alle vom Internet runter sind, glaube ich, ist eine staatliche Zensur völlig überflüssig. Und dass man da technisch überhaupt erstmal was nicht stabil hinkriegen müsste, bevor da überhaupt staatlich was reglementiert werden müsste.
Kannst du das kurz wiederholen? Wir haben es nicht ganz mitbekommen. Was war jetzt die konkrete Folge im Internet, dass es heute im Rathaus Schöneberg gebrannt hat?
Ja, in Berlin gibt es ein wissenschaftliches Netz, das nennt sich Brain. Und das ist nun kaputt, weil das ein Glasfaser ringt.
Ach nein, der Brain ist im Eimer?
Jo, der ist im Eimer. Da hat es gebrannt. 17 Uhr war es dann zu Ende und jetzt hat keiner Internet mehr.
Wobei man muss dazu sagen, da sind natürlich nicht alle in Berlin drüber angeschlossen, sondern im Wesentlichen die Hochschulen und einige Forschungszentren.
Ja, selbst finde ich auch betroffen.
Bist du auch betroffen?
Deshalb wollte ich das eigentlich nur anmerken, dass da eigentlich technisch viel wackelige Sachen noch da sind, als dass man jetzt schon politisch irgendwas regulieren könnte.
Na ja, die technische Sicherheit, dass Presse herausgegeben wird, ist ja auch nicht gegeben, dem Moment, wo die Druckerei abbrennt. Die Frage der Zensur ist ja eigentlich eine andere. Du bist aber grundsätzlich der Meinung, dass man eher weniger reglementieren sollte. Wie würdest du denn dann den Leuten entgegnen, die jetzt danach schreien, aber das geht ja alles nicht, weil das ist ja dann Wildwuchs und dann kann ja jeder kommen?
Na, es gelten ja bereits Gesetze und es ist ja absolut kein rechtsfreier Raum, obwohl der Staat hat ja auch die Möglichkeit, Rechtshilfe zu suchen, zu stellen und dementsprechend nachzukommen, wenn sie konkrete Hinweise haben, wenn irgendein Nutzer dort strafliches Material in das gestellt hat. Bloß wenn dort dann gleich der ganze Provider mit eingesackt wird, mit seiner gesamten Technik, wie das bei diesem Provider-WIP in Österreich passiert ist, dann ist das dann natürlich nicht so toll.
Naja, der Staat hat ja da so ein Problem. Naja, nicht nur das, sondern es ist ja so, dass man rechtssicher versuchen im normalen internationalen Verkehr nur dann stellen kann, wenn es sich tatsächlich um Vergehen handelt, die halt so ernsthaft in so einem Mord oder Unterschlagung oder sowas. Diese sogenannten Ideologie-Delikte, also wo es halt so um Nazi-Geschichten oder sowas geht, die sind ja international ganz unterschiedlich geregelt. In Saudi-Arabien sind ja Sachen verboten, die in Deutschland irgendwie überhaupt nicht verboten sind und so weiter.
Also ganz konkret, was macht man, wenn jetzt irgendwelche gläubigen Mein-Bilder von Frauen dürften nur mit Schleier veröffentlicht werden und wenn da andere Bilder kommen, dann ist das strafbar. Und gibt es da jetzt einen Rechtsweversuch? Ich meine, da ersticken wir.
Bist du denn schon mal auf Kinderpornografie gestoßen im Internet, Martin?
Also normalerweise, wenn man mal... Man kann sogar eigentlich... Also ich hab noch in so einer Computerschule zu tun, wenn man dort die Kinder betrachtet, die sie finden, eigentlich wird ein bisschen klicken, das ist ziemlich schnell und da muss man dann auch ziemlich hinterher sein, dass das dort halt nicht so das Hauptthema ist und dass man mit den Kindern da schon vernünftig mal drüber redet oder halt mit Kindern, wie man mit Kindern redet und denen das beibringt, was das für eine Bedeutung hat und warum das eigentlich nicht so gut ist, wenn sie sich das anschauen, warum das im Gesetz so steht und so weiter.
Pornos oder Kinderpornos?
Also wir suchen ja auch schon seit geraumer Zeit intensiv und wir finden immer nichts.
Echt nicht? Nein.
Dann müsst ihr mal gut suchen.
Eigentlich finden wir sonst immer alles, aber an der Stelle finden wir eigentlich immer nur Seiten, wo Kinderpornografie draufsteht, aber leider nicht drin ist. Oder Gott sei Dank.
Sachen kriegt man eigentlich so auch nicht. Also so die ganzen Sachen, die man so kriegt, sind natürlich eigentlich erst ab 18. Aber zumindest wenn man unter 18 ist, ist das glaube ich schon ein Problem. Aber so verbotene Sachen, wirklich verbotene Sachen, gibt es soweit erst mal nicht so zu finden, auch nicht versuchen.
Dann danken wir für deinen Anruf. Und der nächste Anrufer ist Arnim. Hallo Arnim.
Hallo.
Du bist für viel Reglementierung oder für viel Freiheit im Internet?
Eigentlich für viel Freiheit, weil es gibt eigentlich so viel Reglementierung, ob nur hier oder dort in der gesamten Welt.
Machst du dein Radio leiser?
Willst du schon wieder reglementieren?
Ja, Herr Fahrendt, jetzt wirkt ihr auch viel besser hier im Ohr. Also, wie gesagt, ich bin da eigentlich für unheimlich Freiheit, weil es ist eigentlich mehr der letzte Platz, der uns geblieben ist, um freie Äußerungen zu tätigen, die unreglementiert über die ganze Welt gehen kann.
Und wie geht man da mit Leuten um, die sozusagen, ich meine, es gibt da schon Grenzen, ne?
Ja, ich meine, es gibt Grenzen, aber das ist doch nun so. Ich meine, ich bin jetzt in einem Alter, wo ich sage, ich bin 39, und ich bin eigentlich einer von denjenigen, vor denen mich meine Eltern gewarnt haben. Und genauso werde ich also, oder werden meine Kinder irgendwann mal in dem Alter sein, vor denen ich sie selber gewarnt habe.
Na ja gut, ich meine, solange du das...
Das ist eine Frage der Erziehung. Egal in welcher Form jetzt, wenn ich dich als Elterntal ein gewisser Verobachtlicht oder wie auch immer du das nennen willst, eine Einwirkung auf die Kinder ausübe, würde ich also nicht erreichen, dass da also frei entscheidende Menschen heranwachsen, sondern Leute, die mit Reglementierung aufgewachsen sind, werden halt mit diesen Reglementierungen weiterleben müssen.
Okay, also du bist auch der Meinung, dass zu viel Reglementierung nur schadet.
So ist es auf alle fertig.
Alles klar. Anni?
Beziehungsweise Verlagerung auf die Erziehung.
Wir danken dir für den Anruf. Holger? Hallo Holger. Was ist dein Standpunkt in der Diskussion?
Ja, ich bin deutlich auch gegen zu viel Reglementierung. Ich möchte mich zunächst mal in weiten Teilen an ihm anschließen. Ich wollte es eigentlich versuchen, ganz einfach auf den Punkt zu bringen. Es ist vielleicht zu einfach, um Leben so richtig gerecht zu werden, aber ich versuch's trotzdem mal. Und zwar jede Reglementierung in einer Demokratie dient ja eigentlich dem Schutz der Freiheit der anderen. Und wenn man zu viel Reglementierung macht, schränkt man dadurch die Freiheiten ein. Und ohne dass das jetzt in dem Sinne einen Schutz bringt, weil sonst wär's ja nicht zu viel an Reglementierung. Insofern bin ich der Meinung, was da im Vordergrund steht bei dem Ganzen, ist ja eigentlich immer, dass jeder so viel Freiheit haben sollte.
Dass er die anderen nicht einschränkt. Aber ich hab erst mal konkrete Probleme. Zum Beispiel Nazi-Propaganda. Da hab ich ganz am Anfang gesagt, in Amerika ist das legal, Freedom of Speech. Die haben da sozusagen eine schon noch etwas erweiterte Redefreiheit, auch in ihrer Fassung als wir. Und bei uns ist das schlicht illegal. Und naja, gerade menschenfreundlich ist das auch nicht, was da über die ETA kommt. Die Frage ist ja ganz konkret, wie gehen wir mit so was um? Bestehen wir also auf den Verboten, die wir hier ja gewohnt sind? Und bei uns kann sich in der Zeitung bestimmte Leute nicht in einer bestimmten Art und Weise äußern. In Amerika geht das. Das heißt, wenn ich noch mal deinen Vorwärtner sozusagen kurz zur Ratin ziehen kann, der sagt ja ganz klar, es ist eine Frage der Erziehung auch ein Stück weit. Man muss seinen Kindern eben erklären, was irgendwie oben und unten ist. Wie würdest du das sehen? Kann man da sozusagen, sollte man da jetzt einfach mal dann auch konsequenterweise Nazis zu Wort kommen lassen? Oder hat das Ganze doch solche Grenzen, dass man da sein muss? Also hier dann irgendwie nicht. Also wie geht man mit diesen Leuten um? Oder vielmehr, wie geht man mit den doch erweiterten Freiheitsvorstellungen der Amerikaner zum Beispiel um?
Also ein Punkt, den ich dazu sagen möchte, ist das, so meine Erfahrung ist, dass wenn sich jemand in dieser Richtung reißt, dass es dann immer genug Stimmen gibt, also irgendwie die Mehrheit der Stimmen, die dagegen halten oder dagegen argumentieren. Also wenn es jetzt zum Beispiel Newsgroups gibt, das ist irgendwie ein ganz wichtiger Punkt am Internet, dass das nun noch eine Möglichkeit ist, dass jeder quasi eine gleichlaute Stimme hat. Das ist ja ansonsten im Leben meistens nicht so. Wenn ich irgendwas sage, dann hört das vielleicht mein Freundeskreis. Wenn Helmut Kohl irgendwas sagt, dann hört es im extremen Fall die ganze Welt.
Bist du dann der Meinung, dass die Regelung der Amerikaner, was die Freiheit der Sprache betrifft, sehr viel besser ist, als der ist-Zustand hier in Deutschland?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Das blüht halt in dem Fall gewisse Probleme, wo eben nicht jeder eine gleiche Lautestimme hat. Aber im Internet bin ich eigentlich schon der Meinung, dass es sich da irgendwo insofern selbst regelt, als wenn jemand etwas in der Richtung äußert, dann immer genug Leute auch dagegenhalten. Den anderen Punkt, den ich noch anführen wollte, sehe ich da ganz gewaltige Probleme. Ihr hattet ja vorhin ein Interview mit einem Niederländer, wo es unter anderem auch darum ging, dass der in Deutschland unter Umständen verrückt werden könnte.
Verrückt oder verhaftet?
Verrückt, ja, also verhaftet. Und da frage ich mich, wie soll dieser Mensch so im allgemeinen Fall das überhaupt wissen, dass er gegen Gesetze in fremden Staaten verstößt? Es kann doch niemand irgendwie die Gesetze, die überall auf der Welt gelten, irgendwo im Kopf haben. Und wenn er jetzt irgendwas in den Niederlanden auf einer FDP-Seite oder auf einem BWW irgendwie anbietet, dann irgendwie die Folgen abschätzen, die das haben kann, dadurch, dass das überall in der Welt abrufbar ist.
Na gut, ich meine, nach derselben Logik müsste natürlich auch die chinesische Regierung zum Beispiel Spiegelredakteure bei der Durchreise durch China erschießen, wenn sie das nicht ohnehin in Englisch beruhen, die halt über die chinesische Führung irgendwie in einer anderen Art und Weise die Politik berichten.
Also ich denke, dieses Problem der weltweiten Gerichtsbarkeit wird sich irgendwie in den nächsten absehbaren 10, 20 Jahren nicht wirklich lösen. Allein die Vorstellung, dass Gesetze, die über unterschiedliche Kulturkreise gehen, sich gegenseitig beeinflussen, dürfte doch einigen Juristen Aga Albträume bereiten.
Naja, oder aber vielmehr, das ist irgendwie die Zukunft, aus der man irgendwie, also ich meine, Jura wird sicherlich eins der...
Einträglichst ähnlicher werden, ja?
Einträglichsten Gebiete werden, wenn die Juristen an diesen Unklarheiten verdienen, verdienen sie sich da jetzt schon.
Das ist ja, bei sehr schön Ansatz fand war eigentlich die Geschichte gerade, dass sich das selbst reguliert. Dass also immer, wenn irgendeine Scheiße passiert, einfach in so einem großen Gefüge, es immer auch sehr viele Leute gibt, die sagen, hey Moment mal, das ist ein totaler Unfug.
Es geht ja sogar so weit, dass die Diskussionskultur bei denen ja so weit ist, dass selbst einige Nazis wiederum Verweise auf jüdische Kritikerseiten unten auf ihren Seiten drauf haben.
Und andersrum. Also ich meine, wir müssen hier, das ist letztendlich alte Welt, neue Welt. In der alten Welt und diese repräsentativen Instanzen, Politiker genannt, die wir da haben, die gehen einfach mit dem Verständnis der alten Media raus, die glauben für uns, uns beschützen zu müssen. Also denen unterstelle ich noch nicht mal Bösartigkeit, wenn die da irgendwie einen Internetserviceboarder verhaften, sondern die glauben wirklich, es ist zum Wohle der Menschheit. Und um uns da vor zu beschützen, und das haben wir aber an einigen Stellen sozusagen im Netz, kann man sagen, schon selbst übernommen. Bloß muss das natürlich a, nach außen kommuniziert werden und b, muss das auch vermittelt werden, denjenigen, die jetzt irgendwie neu ans Netz kommen, die vielleicht auf die Telekom Werbung hineingefallen sind, die Freiheit ist grenzenlos im Internet. Und dann natürlich auch glauben, sie können hier irgendwie Schweinegeln, Kinderpornos verkaufen und was weiß ich was alles tun. Also grenzenlose Freiheit ist vielleicht nicht ganz die richtige Bezeichnung. Jetzt gibt es da schon Spielregeln. Ich denke, dazu machen wir da eine eigene Sendung.
Und vor allem mal ein bisschen Musik, bevor wir dann in der letzten Stunde auf unser zweites großes Thema kommen wollen.
Ist das nicht das dritte?
Naja, ich weiß nicht. Also wir hatten jetzt bisher die Zensur im Vordergrund und wollen jetzt dann auch mal den zweiten Aspekt, nämlich die Sache mit der Verschlüsselung näher beleuchten. Und dort so machen wir erst einmal ein wenig Musik. Hier ist Chaosradio und als nächsten Anrufer haben wir den Gregor. Hallo Gregor. Du hast eine Frage.
Ja, konkretes Thema. Es ist ein Wurr nochmal, bevor jetzt Verschlüsselung kommt. Und zwar...
Glück gehabt.
Was kann jetzt der gemeine Internet-User tun, wenn er feststellt, dass sein Service Provider, sagen wir bestimmte Newsgroups, einfach gar nicht anbietet?
Was ein normaler Benutzer tun kann.
Wenn er feststellt, dass er irgendwie auf irgendwelche Server nicht zugreifen kann oder so.
Da gibt es viele Wege. Der einfachste ist, man nimmt einen anderen News-Server. Es gibt weltweit mehrere zigtausend News-Server. Davon sind einige offen. Das heißt, einige Provider bieten einen Zugang öffentlich auf ihren Server entweder aus Unwissenheit oder absichtlich. Die findet man im Netz selbst. Es gibt also zum Beispiel Sites, wo auf offene NNTP-Server hingewiesen wird und so weiter. Dann dreht man die ein, zum Beispiel in Netscape. Schönes Detail ist, dass auch über T-Online damit möglich ist, tatsächlich auf News-Server, also auf Inhalte, zuzugreifen, die möglicherweise strafbaren Inhalts sind, eben weil sie aus weiß der Teufel woher kommen, wo sich da niemand wirklich drum kümmert. Und damit macht sich genau im Sinne wie vorhin der Provider in Österreich die Telekom strafbar der zur Verfügung Stellung und des Transportes dieser Inhalte öffentlich und müsste damit eigentlich beschlagnahmt werden.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel news.uni-hohenheim.de ausprobieren, da kriegst du eigentlich alles.
Na gut, aber jetzt nochmal kurz die Frage an Steini. Was weiß denn der Teufel diesbezüglich so und wie kann ich ihn fragen?
Welcher Teufel?
Na du sagst eben, was ist der Teufel, welcher news ist.
Witz für schlechte Witze.
Ist die Frage des Hörers damit beantwortet oder nicht? War der das sozusagen konkret genug? Weil die Frage ist halt tatsächlich, also es ist auch so, dass es in der Tat die Alternative gibt, den Serviceprovider zu verklagen, weil der hat ja auch dir gegenüber die Verpflichtung.
Ja, aber die meisten haben halt...
Es gibt einen juristischen Formbrief dazu.
Aber die meisten haben Geschäftsbedingungen, denen sie halt irgendwie klar dir sagen, dass du hiermit unterschreibst, dass du dich damit einverstanden erklärst, dass du nicht das ganze Internet vollständig und nahe Schönheit genießen kannst, sondern dass es halt sein kann, dass aus technischen oder juristischen Gründen bestimmte Teile nicht verfügbar sind.
Gut, dann müssen wir also feststellen, wir haben hier... Moment, darf ich mal ganz kurz? Wir haben hier nicht den Nutella-Effekt. Es ist nicht so, dass überall wo Internet drauf steht, auch Internet drin ist, richtig?
Naja, aber eigentlich schon sein sollte. Also wenn ein Internet-Serviceprovider auf den Kunden zugeht und sagt, ich gebe dir Internet, dann muss er das auch tun. Die Frage, die Gregor gestellt hat, ist ja, wenn mein Internet-Serviceprovider mir bestimmte Newsgroups nicht gibt, was ist dann?
Zum Beispiel?
Das ist aber eher eine technische Feinheit, dass die meisten Internet-Serviceprovider, neben dem eigentlichen Internetzugang, dir auch noch lokal, also nah an dir dran, alle Newsgroups des Netzes vorrätig sind.
Moment mal, Moment mal, aber News sind doch Bestandteil des Internet.
Ja, aber der News-Server des Internet-Serviceproviders ist ja kein Pflichtprogramm, es gibt ja andere News-Server im Netz, die ja letztlich genauso nur einen Klick entfernt sind, aber eben nicht unbedingt vom Netz her so nah ist. Also dass der Internet-Serviceprovider einen eigenen News-Server vorrätig hat, ist nicht unbedingt Pflicht, wohl aber die Regel. Wir erleben das ja auch immer wieder, dass Internet-Serviceprovider bestimmte Newsgroups ausklang. Das kommt vor. Und wenn du das halt umgehen willst, dann nimmst du einfach einen anderen News-Server. Wenn dir ein Internet-Serviceprovider dir den Zugang zu einem bestimmten News-Server verbietet, dann ist es schon ein kritischer Punkt. Und in dem Moment sollte man auch auf den Serviceprovider zugehen und sagen, hey, was machst du da eigentlich? Warum sperrst du jetzt bestimmte IP-Adressen oder bestimmte DNS-Einträge? Das will ich nicht. Dann wechsle ich zu Not den Provider.
Also ganz konkret, alter Vista, Fragen nach Open NNTP Server. Und dann kommst du weiter.
Hat das deine Frage beantwortet?
Nur, dass mit dem Formbrief wollte ich nochmal fragen. Ich bin jetzt nicht beim kommerziellen Provider, sondern bei der TV-Uhr Berlin. Ich denke mal, da muss man damit zufrieden sein, was man kriegt, oder?
Also bei den Unis gibt es auch Beschlüsse von den jeweiligen akademischen Gremien dazu, wie mit News umgegangen wird. In den meisten Fällen ist es so, dass da beschlossen wird, dass Gruppen, die nicht für einen unmittelbaren Universitätsbetrieb notwendig sind, dass die halt meistens nicht mehr geführt werden. Also zum Beispiel Berliner Unis sind zwischenzeitlich praktisch alle Sexpunkt-Sterne-Gruppen und umgekehrt nicht mehr erreichbar und so weiter und so fort. Das hat aber auch teilweise Hauigen versichern lassen, mit der Last zu tun, weil einige von diesen Newsgroups befördern tatsächlich Megabytes pro Tag und da haben die halt einfach irgendwann keinen Bock mehr drauf gehabt.
Das ist absolut verständlich, aber jetzt ruf ich zum Beispiel konkret die Newsgroups, die früher mal T-Netz-Drogen hieß und jetzt glaube ich Z-Netz-Alz-Drogen.
Ja, die ist unbenannt worden. Da haben viele Leute gedacht, dass die gesperrt wurde, aber die wurde tatsächlich nur unbenannt. Irr, irgendwas noch mit Drogen, aber irgendwas davor. Hab ich jetzt leider nicht verraten. Vielleicht bist du irgendwie auf IRC. Andrea, schick uns doch mal eine SMS mit der aktuellen Newsgroup. Dann geben wir das nachher durch, okay? Zum nächsten Punkt, die NSA. Das Ohr des großen Bruders. Wozu soll ich eigentlich verschlüsseln? Das fragen sich sicher die meisten Menschen, die mit den Auf- und Abs der Kryptografie-Debatte konfrontiert werden. Mich, so wird der normalsterbliche Computernutzer sagen, lohnt es doch gar nicht abzuhören. Ich hab sowieso nichts zu verbergen, verschlüsseln tun doch nur die Militärs, Spione und Mafiosi. Sollen sie es doch verbieten, dann ist endlich Ordnung und Sicherheit. Die wenigsten wissen, in welchem Umfang tatsächlich elektronische Medien abgehört und ausgewertet werden, mit welchen Zielen dies erfolgt und durch wen. Im Folgenden werden wir einen kurzen Blick auf die größte und mächtigste Informationsbeschaffungsorganisation werfen, die zurzeit operiert. Die National Security Agency, kurz NSA genannt, ist der Geheimdienst, der in den USA ausschließlich für die Beschaffung elektronischer Informationen zuständig ist. Die NSA unterhält weltweit Dutzende Stationen, die mit den modernsten Empfangs- und Auswertungsgeräten bestückt sind, das menschlicher Forschungsgeist entwickelt hat. Die meisten dieser Systeme wurden in den eigenen Forschungslabors entwickelt, in eigenen Chipfabriken und Werkstätten gefertigt und sind niemandem sonst zugänglich. Abgehört werden Satellitenverbindungen, Transkontinentalkabel, Funktelefonnetze, Richtfunklinks, Glasfaserleitungen und Funkverbindungen. Wo es nicht möglich ist, Stationen zu platzieren, werden praktisch alle Arten von Funkkommunikationen von speziell entwickelten Satelliten aufgefangen. Das alles richtet sich nicht nur gegen die bösen Russen und Chinesen. Große Teile des Systems werden zur systematischen Ausforschung der Verbündeten der USA benutzt. Regelmäßig werden US-Konzerne mit der von der NSA aufgefangenen Informationen versorgt, die ihnen Vorteile im globalen Konkurrenzkampf bringen. Ob es nun um Angebote, Preise, Eigentumsverschiebungen oder den Kontostand geht, praktisch alles geht irgendwo durch die Filtersysteme der NSA. Um der gigantischen Datenmenge herzuwerden und die relevanten und interessanten Übertragungen herauszufischen, arbeitet der Dienst mit sehr großen Rechneranlagen, die alles nach Stichworten durchsuchen. Dies funktioniert sowohl bei elektronisch vorliegenden Daten, wie E-Mails oder Buchungstransaktionen, als auch bei Sprache und Fax, die mit Hilfe eigens entwickelter und meist nicht frei verfügbarer Algorithmen analysiert werden. Um den eigenen Aufwand in Grenzen zu halten, wurde in den 80er Jahren ein gemeinsames Netz mit den Verbündeten des sogenannten UKUSA-Abkommens aufgebaut, das die abzusehende Steigerung der Datentransaktionen auffangen sollte. Dazu wurden rund um die Welt auf den Territorien von Australien, Neuseeland, Kanada und Großbritannien Stationen errichtet, die in der Regie der jeweiligen lokalen Dienste betrieben werden. Kern jeder Station ist ein schneller Rechner, in den jeder der beteiligten Dienste Stichworte einspielen darf. Die den Stichworten entsprechenden Nachrichten werden ihnen dann zugeleitet. Natürlich ist die NSA auch hier etwas gleicher als die anderen Dienste. Ein Stichwort auf ihren Rechner einzutragen ist für den kleinen Bruder deutlich schwieriger als umgekehrt. Das Netz trägt den Namen Echelon und erfasst alles von Hongkonger Börsentransaktionen über japanischen Botschaftsfunk und russische E-Mails. Die Echelon Station auf deutschem Gebiet steht in Bad Aibling. Deutsche Dienste haben hier nichts zu sagen. Offiziell wird das Gelände vom amerikanischen Militär betrieben. Eine der Spezialitäten der NSA ist das Brechen von Codes und Verschlüsselungssystemen. Ob nun diplomatische Übertragung oder Strategiepapiere ausländischer Konzerne, die meisten konventionellen Verschlüsselungssysteme sind für die NSA ein offenes Buch. Nur bestimmte Arten von Verschlüsselungen, die auf dem mathematischen Problem der Faktorisierbarkeit großer Primzahlen beruhen, stellen offenbar ein Problem für die Code Knacker dar. Trotzdem sich die NSA für über Jahre und Jahrzehnte hinweg die besten Mathematiker von den Universitäten holte, ist es allem anscheinend nach bisher nicht gelungen, Verfahren wie RSA oder IDEA zu knacken. Aus diesem Grund betreibt die NSA seit mehreren Jahren massive politische Einflussnahme auf die Politik. Ob die National Security Agency mit dem Versuch, nicht von ihr zu knackende Verfahren zu verbieten, weltweit durchkommt, erscheint fraglich, aber nicht unmöglich. Hier ist Chaosradio, unser Thema heute Kontrolle elektronischer Medien. Wir sind jetzt übergeschwenkt auf die Verschlüsselungsdebatte und haben eben gehört, was die NSA alles so treibt, um euch mal einen Einblick zu geben, wie heute zutage schon real abgehört wird.
Wenn das Mikrofon funktioniert, ein Überschränkter zu sehen, was hat das mit uns zu tun? Es ist so, dass die USA Exportbeschränkungen für starke kryptografische Verfahren haben, damit also ihre Argumentation nach, z.B. die Irakis, also der Hussein mit seinen Militärleuten, nicht amerikanische Export, also amerikanische Technologie kauft, um dann so Verschlüsse zu übertragen, dass sie es nicht mehr nicht mitlesen können. Nur ist es so, dass diese Regelungen bis vor Kurzem dann auch als Munition eben galten. Kryptografische Verfahren und Unterlagen logischerweise neben Department of Defense, dem Verteidigungsministerium. Seit Dezember 96 ist das nicht mehr so. Da gab es eine scheinbare Auflockerung. Das heißt, die Sachen gelten jetzt nicht mehr als Waffe, sondern als exportbeschränkte Güter, die den Department of Commerce unterstellt sind. Und konkret heißt das, dass also Sachen oder RSA, dieses konkrete Verfahren, was sich mehr oder weniger durchgesetzt hat, also alle Schlüssel, die länger als 40 Bits sind, dürfen nur innerhalb von Amerikas benutzt werden. Software, die das macht. Und zum Beispiel Lotus Notes ist ein Software, das benutzt zwar 56 Bit lange Schlüssel, aber 16 Bit hinterlegen die gleich bei der NSA. Und deswegen dürfen sie den Rest exportieren. Das heißt, man bekommt in Deutschland zwar eine Version mit 56 Bit, aber die 40 Bit, die können sie knacken, und die 16 Bit haben sie ohnehin liegen. Nun ist die Frage, nach welcher Argumentation wird das eigentlich in anderen Ländern gehandhabt? Und die Sache ist die, dass die Amerikaner mit dem Argument, es ginge um die nationale Sicherheit, um die Gefahr, dass organisierte Kriminelle verschüssen können und keiner kann es mitlesen, müssten also auch befreundete Regierungen sich diesen Umgang anschließen. Und in den Gesetzen explizit drin steht, das ist unter www.epic.org auch nachzulesen, da sind also diese neuen Gesetze nachzulesen, dass innerhalb von zwei Jahren eine globale Key Recovery Struktur aufgebaut werden soll mit allen kooperationsbereiten Staaten, das heißt alle Staaten, die irgendwie mit Amerika mitspielen, die sollen diese Regelungen aufführen und also da soll dann immer nur Verfahren erlaubt werden, wo letztendlich mitgelesen werden kann.
Das ist das, was Key Recovery heißt, ja?
Das ist sozusagen das, was Key Recovery heißt, beziehungsweise da werden so Strukturen errichtet. Und es hat sich also zugetragen im Dezember diesen Jahres, dass eine amerikanische Delegation unseren Innenminister Kanter und unseren Kanzler Kohle wohl besucht hat. Der offizielle Anlass ist völlig unklar, aber was da passiert ist, ist, dass die sozusagen als Kooperationspartner in diesem Vorhaben gewonnen wurden, um also auch in Deutschland entsprechend Beschränkungen des Einsatzes starker Verschlüsselungsverfahren durchzusetzen. Und das ist das, was da jetzt so ein bisschen vor sich hin köchelt. Offiziell gab es Anhörungen, die Wirtschaft hat da natürlich ein Problem mit, weil das ist im Prinzip staatlich verordnete Unsicherheit, beispielsweise für Banken.
Das heißt, dass sozusagen die NSA grundsätzlich, dass bei der NSA die Schlüssel hinterlegt werden, die in Deutschland erlaubt sind?
Ja, bzw. dass die NSA auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise immer die Möglichkeit hat, mitzulesen. Da gibt es verschiedene Methoden, auch die in einem sogenannten Trust Center dann also die Schlüssel aufzubewahren. Das sollen dann vertrauenswürdige Instanzen sein. Bloß gut, die haben dann halt kleine Hintertürchen. Jetzt haben wir aber das nächste Mal einen Hörer, denke ich. Genau, jetzt schauen wir mal rein.
Jetzt holen wir mal Stefan. Hallo Stefan.
Ja, hallo.
Du hast lange warten müssen.
So habe ich immerhin mal technisch telefon gehört.
Wie war das?
Zu deiner Frage.
Gut, was ich dazu sagen wollte, ist eigentlich zweierlei. Und zwar das eine, ich meine, als Privatmensch sieht die Sache ja von der Argumentation aus ja relativ klar aus. Nämlich klipp und klar, ich poche halt auf mein Briefgeheimnis. Und wenn ich einen Brief irgendwo einwerfe und den gut zuklebe, dann gehe ich auch davon aus, dass sich da keiner erdreißt, den zwischendurch aufzumachen und wieder zuzukleben. Ich kann das ja schließlich immerhin erreichen, dass mein Gegenüber, dem ich da was mitteilen will, auf jeden Fall überprüfen kann, ob er offen oder nicht offen war. Sobald ich feststellen würde, dass er zwischendurch geöffnet worden ist, muss man sich halt was einfallen lassen. Aber ich habe doch immerhin bei diesem konventionellen Weg einen Brief zu schicken, da doch relativ viel Überblick, was da zwischendurch passiert. Genau das wäre ja letztlich, was den privaten Verkehr im Internet angeht, eigentlich auch zu verlangen. Das wäre zumindest erstmal ein Standpunkt, den man als Privatmann so haben kann. Das andere ist aber, wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, was ihr da alles erzählt habt, was jetzt da die Amis machen, die Geschichte eben, dass zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie Industriespionage ja sehr systematisch betrieben wird und dass es schließlich auch nicht unbedingt nur bei den Amis der Fall nur machen, die das vielleicht noch ein bisschen geschickter als andere. Aber letztlich ist das ja was, was sich in einem ganz bewusst rechtsfrei gehaltenen Raum praktiziert wird und man macht das und man hat da halt so seine Vorteile draus. Und das heißt, solange das rechtsfrei ist, das Ganze, ist ihm natürlich auch sehr schwer beizukommen. Und interessant daran ist doch eigentlich, dass jetzt versucht wird, von jetzt in dem Fall jetzt der US-Regierung aus das Ganze sozusagen in den Rechtsraum zu heben, um dann anschließend sagen zu können, wir haben Gesetze, die vorschreiben, dass ihr euch alle so benehmen müsst, damit wir euch lesen können. Und ich meine, das ist, also letztlich beißt sich ja irgendwo in den Schwanz, weil eigentlich täten wir ja besser daran still und heimlich zu versuchen, diese kurzendlich zu knacken und sobald sie was gefunden haben, tunlichst die Klappe halten.
Ja gut, aber an der Stelle muss ich in deiner Argumentation mal kurz Bewusstseins erweitern, und dann hoffentlich eingreifen, weil deren Problem ist nicht, dass sie nicht alle kurz knacken können. Gut, es mag einige Verfahren geben, mit denen sie noch echte Probleme haben, wo es lange dauert, aber im Grunde genommen haben die natürlich auch Maschinen, mit denen sie RSA kurz knacken können. Plus diese Maschinen kosten wie auch immer. Jedenfalls ist es so, diese Maschinen kosten viel Geld und kosten viel Aufwand. Und in dem Moment, wo jeder in Anführungszeichen das Recht hat, die zu benutzen und dann auch entsprechend seine Liebesbriefe, zum Beispiel die was Internet schickt, verschlüsselt, haben die einfach ein Problem. Das heißt, die haben hochqualifizierte Leute und hochteure Maschinen, die Liebesbriefe entschlüsseln und das ist natürlich nichts in der Aktion. Und deswegen haben sie natürlich ein Interesse daran, weil man muss ja auch klar sehen, diese Maschinen kosten Geld, die Regierung investiert Geld, warum tut sie das? Weil sich das irgendwann rentiert. Stichwort Wirtschaftsspionage, dass sie also in anderen Ländern mitbekommen, was Firmen dort entwickeln, dass wiederum ihrer Industrie mitteilen können. Das ist übrigens nach amerikanischem Gesetz auch so geregelt, dass die Geheimdienste, also amerikanischen Unternehmen, von ihren Erkenntnissen da Informationstransfers haben und so fort. Das heißt, es geht im Grunde genommen darin, dass sie den Einfluss oder den Einsatz solcher starker Verfahren eben auf diejenigen beschränken, die sie wirklich interessieren und den in Anführungszeichen Otto Normalburger mit seinen Liebesbriefen eben außerhalb ihrer teuren Maschinen haben. Das ist sozusagen also der wahre Grund.
Na klar, nur interessant dabei ist doch eigentlich, dass letztlich irgendwo ist doch klar, dass man das so nicht handeln kann, weil das ganze System, das ganze Netz ist ja nun schließlich gerade so aufgebaut, dass sich das im Grunde genommen nicht zentralisieren lässt und eben halt die Sachen gehen halt so seinen Weg und es geht halt jedes Mal einen anderen Weg und das ist ja eben auch so gut so und jetzt versucht werden soll, aus diesem unglaublichen Wust von Sachen das Promille rauszusuchen, was für die jetzt interessant ist, muss er weiter...
Das werden sie relativ leicht herausfinden können, das ist nicht so sehr das Problem. Wir danken ja auf jeden Fall erstmal dafür einen Anruf, Stefan, wir müssen gleich hier weitermachen mit Kurznachrichten und schalten jetzt erstmal auf die Musik weiter für Marianne. Hier ist Chaosradio, Kontrolle elektronischer Medien. Wir sind jetzt wieder offen für eure Anrufe unter 0331 74 81 110 und wir starten jetzt durch mit... Wer war gleich der nächste? War das der Ralf? Das war der Florian. Hallo Florian. Du hast eine Frage? Einen Kommentar.
Ich wollte nur einmal ein Statement abgeben, erstmal zur Verschlüsselung, finde ich das ziemlich unfair von den Amis, wenn sie sowieso alles entschlüsseln können, kann ich meine Liebesbriefe auch gleich an alle öffentlich verschicken, das hat denselben Effekt, finde ich. Und dann wollte ich eigentlich noch zur Zensur fahren was sagen, ich habe mich damit schon mal beschäftigt und habe ich eben mal im Grundgesetz geblättert und habe ich doch glatt was gefunden. Wenn ich mal vorlesen dürfte, es wäre Artikel 5 Absatz 1, Meinungsinformations- und Pressefreiheit und so weiter. Jeder hat das Recht seine Meinung in Wortschrift und Bild frei zu äußern und zu verbreiten und sich aus allgemein zugänglichen Quellen ungehindert zu unterrichten. Die Pressefreiheit und die Freiheit der Berichterstattung, die Schronfung und Film werden gewährleistet.
Und steht da auch wie bei den meisten anderen Grundgesetzen dann dann als nächstes noch Einschränkungen dürfen nur aufgrund eines Gesetzes vorgenommen werden?
Diese Rechte finden ihre Schranken in den Vorschriften der allgemeinen Gesetze.
Siehste, das ist das Problem, was ich mit unserem Grundgesetz hab. Da stehen immer prima Sachen drin und dann steht da als nächstes immer ja und Einschränkungen aufgrund eines Gesetzes.
Das gilt jetzt leider nicht, weil das dann so die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen, die kommen dann auch hinterher. Und das Kleingedruckte.
Aber ich danke dir für den ersten Satz, ich denke, wenn wir angemacht sind, dann werden wir einfach den zweiten Abseits streichen und dann geht das schon.
So, der nächste ist Ralf. Hallo Ralf.
Ich hab mal folgende Frage und zwar zu diesem Verschlüsselungsverfahren, zu diesem RSA ist das, ne? Wie gesagt würde, es darf also dieses Verschlüsselungsprogramm jetzt nur mit einer, also außerhalb Amerika oder was, was ich verkaufe werde, oder was, mit einer maximal Höchstgröße des Schlüsseles. Ist das soweit richtig schonmal?
Nein, nee, es ist so, dass die Firma RSA sitzt ja in den USA und unterliegt als solche einer Exportkontrolle. Also Produkte dieser Firma RSA, die halt länger als eine bestimmte Schlüssellänge haben, dürfen halt außerhalb der USA, also aus den USA nicht exportiert werden. Aber es ist nunmal so, dass der Algorithmus, nachdem die meisten Verschlüsselungsprodukte von RSA funktionieren, der ist halt bekannt und der wurde halt auch außerhalb der USA nachprogrammiert mehrfach und der ist halt per Internet auch in die weite Welt gelangt. Also sozusagen die Verbreitung dieser Verschlüsselstechnologie ist durch dieses Exportverbot von den Amerikanern nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
Außerdem gab es da einen sehr schönen Versuch, das auf Basis des Freedom of Speech durchzudrücken. Es hat also tatsächlich eine Richterin entschieden, dass einer, der ein Programm geschrieben hat, den Source Code veröffentlichen darf, weil das unter die Meinungsfreiheit fällt und in welcher Sprache diese Meinung kundgetan wird, sei hier unerheblich und darunter fallen eben auch Programmiersprachen.
Gut, aber das heißt auch im Klartext, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, du bekommst dieses Verschlüsselungsverfahren, du kannst dir damit deine, ich sage jetzt mal beliebig lange oder zumindest lang genug Schlüssel selber erzeugen und die halt eben deinen öffentlichen Schlüssel verbreiten überall hin und jeder, der das Programm selber dann auch wieder kompoliert hat, erinnert auch dieses. Dieses Ding eigentlich, also ist diese Verschlüsselung fächig doch möglich, auch sicher möglich, so dass die, dieses A und so weiter nicht zuhören können, wie das gedacht ist. Also ist doch eigentlich schon gelöst, das Problem.
Nee, ist es nicht gelöst, weil die Regelungen, die halt angestrebt werden von verschiedenen Regierungen, werden halt möglicherweise so ähnlich aussehen wie zurzeit in Frankreich. Da ist es so, dass starke Verschlüsselung, also zum Beispiel PHP, verboten ist, dass sie dir aber erstmal nicht irgendwie auf den Pelz rücken, wenn du es benutzt, sondern dass sie es halt benutzen, wenn sie dir sowieso irgendwie an den Kahn pissen wollen.
Nein, das ist nicht, juristisch ist das nicht ganz korrekt.
Na gut, okay, aber wir brauchen jetzt nicht Gesetz auseinanderversehen.
Ja, die formulieren das viel höflicher, die sagen, das ist lizenzierungspflichtig.
Also es läuft halt darauf hinaus, dass der Staat halt bestimmen will, wer starke Verschlüsselung verwenden darf. Und die Entwürfe für die deutschen Gesetze, die so diskutiert werden, sehen halt zum Beispiel vor, dass ein Hinweis darauf, dass du starke Verschlüsselung verwendest, die nicht lizenziert ist, weitere Ermittlungen rechtfertigt. Das heißt, sie gehen davon aus, wer was verschlüsselt hat, was zu verbergen, also kriegt er erstmal auf den Kopf.
Das hat U-Deutsch-Bände dann rausgefunden, wird verbreitet an den Schlüssel, der ist so und so lang. Wenn dieses Gesetz finden, also durchgeführt werden würde, oder in Deutschland eingeführt werden würde, dann muss ich also damit rechnen, dass die Leute bei mir vor der Hausstehung und meine Rechte, also ich suche das gut an.
Möglicherweise, möglicherweise auch nicht. Es hängt halt immer dann vom Gutdünken ab. Also es besteht dann sozusagen keinerlei Rechtssicherheit mehr an diesen Punkten, sondern es handelt sich dann höchstwahrscheinlich um relativ wirkliches Verfahren. Also die größten Probleme, die sie da halt haben, sind natürlich die Industrie, weil die wollen natürlich sicher verschlüsseln, weil sie haben erhebliche Probleme mit Wirtschaftsspionage und da gab es schon etliche Fälle, wo ihnen auf Dreh durch die Lappen gegangen sind, wegen nicht vorhandener oder mangelhafter Verschlüsselung. Und von daher wird wahrscheinlich, wenn es ein deutsches Kryptografiegesetz geben sollte, es so aussehen, dass halt für den Privatmann Verschlüsselung irgendwie erschwert oder untersagt ist oder die Schlüssellänge begrenzt ist, oder nur bestimmte Verfahren zugelassen sind oder der Schlüssel hinterlegt werden muss. Aber dass bei der Industrie halt irgendwie alle vorhandenen Augen zugedrückt werden und die halt so stark wie möglich verschlüsseln können, nehmen sich halt die Lizenzen dafür hoch.
Aber das funktioniert ja am Ende nicht. Also das ist ja nicht durchsetzbar. Ich denke, es ist auch genau dann nicht durchsetzbar, wenn tatsächlich alle immer verschlüsseln. Genau, in dem Moment ist nämlich überhaupt nicht mehr feststellbar, wer verschlüsselt denn mit was und wie überhaupt genau und recht zu leben.
Das ist ein klein bisschen auch naiv, weil Haschisch ist auch verboten. Klar, irgendwie kann man hier überall Haschisch kaufen und Haschisch rauchen und trotzdem, wenn irgendwie ein Staatsanwalt dir was böset, dann hat er damit schon mal was. Also ich möchte mich zumindest, ich meine, das Problem ist ja auch, dass hier irgendwie große Bevölkerungskreise, die eigentlich verschlüsseln müssen, weil sie ihr gutes Recht ist, ihre Privatsphäre auch im Netz irgendwie zu gewährleisten, einfach verunsichert werden dadurch, dass es illegal gemacht wird. Weil ein normaler Mensch, der hält sich nur mal Gesetze dazu, sind die da.
Ja, genau das ist der Punkt, weil wenn jetzt nämlich die Leute verunsichert sind und die Verschlüsselung nicht benutzen, dann sind automatisch alle die kriminalisiert, die es trotzdem tun. Und da braucht man dann nicht mehr zu knacken, das sind dann nämlich nur noch einige wenige, da geht man dann nach Hause und guckt durchs Fenster.
Ralf, deine Frage damit beantwortet. So, bevor ich den nächsten dran nehme, nämlich Heiko, will ich noch kurz ein Versprechen wahrmachen, nämlich kurz den Namen dieser News Group nennen. Das ist jetzt bei mir eingetroffen. Die News Group, die halt vorher irgendwie T-Netz, irgendwas Drogen hieß, die heißt jetzt de.soc.drogen. Hallo, was hast du für uns? Und du wolltest was richtig stellen?
Ja, es geht um den Schlüssel in 2024, bitte. Das ist der Schlüssel mit der militärischen Sicherheitsstufe.
2048 ist es mittlerweile.
Wie bitte? 2048, gut, okay. Also ich habe noch den mit 2024, aber der unterliegt den Konstruktionen der NSA. Und den habe ich mir über einen Remailer besorgt, in dem ich mich ganz einfach einge- linked habe. Wie bekannt ist, wird ja beim Remailer einfach der HIDA verändert. Und dadurch ist es möglich, konnte nicht zu mir zurückverfolgt werden, dass ich mich dort auf dem PGP Rechner einge- linked habe. Und die Fragen habe ich dort alle mit ja beantwortet, die dort auftauchen.
Redest du jetzt von deinem eigenen Schlüssel, den du für deine persönliche Verschlüsselung verwendest? Den müsstest du doch eigentlich selber generiert haben.
Mein Schlüssel schon, aber den habe ich mit Hilfe des Algorithmus der 1024-Bit-Verschlüsselung.
Das heißt, du hast dir das PGP-Programm über einen Remailer bezogen. Bis jetzt der Auffassung, das könnte man nicht zurückvollziehen.
Du solltest dazu wissen, geht mal. Knapp das dreiviertel Jahr her und bisher hab ich überhaupt noch keine Probleme.
Aber es ist halt so, dass man vielleicht wissen sollte, dass eine der attraktivsten Dinge, die man als Geheimdienst im Internet betreiben kann, sind natürlich Remailer und Analymeriser. Aber du hättest eigentlich nicht so einen Aufwand machen brauchen. PGP und andere Verschlüsselungsverfahren sind im Internet auch auf nicht-amerikanischen Servern weitestgehend verfügbar. Also auch auf deutschen Universitätsservern findet man eigentlich im Regelfall PGP für die verschiedensten Plattformen. Da braucht man sich nicht wirklich Sorgen machen, dass man das nicht bekommt.
Aber ja, okay, aber den Algorithmus für die Verschlüsselung...
Den findest du zum Beispiel in jedem deutschen Buchladen erhaltlichen Büchern wie Applied Cryptography von Bruce Schneier.
Ja, auch den der von der NSA mit Exportbeschränkungen.
Ja, da liegt in der deutschen Ausgabe...
Das ist das Schöne daran.
In der deutschen Ausgabe liegt halt die Diskette nicht dabei, weil sozusagen der abgetippte Source auf dieser Diskette wäre halt illegal. Allerdings ist der Source halt im Buch komplett legal, weil er halt unter freier Meinungsäußerung fällt. Also diese Gesetze sind, das wissen die Amis auch selber, extrem löchrig und die Verschlüsselung ist schon draußen. Also diese Verschlüsselungsrestriktierung ist auch mittlerweile bei den Amis, also bei den amerikanischen Firmen, so dermaßen unbeliebt, weil sie Marktchancen zunagelt. Also zum Beispiel Lotus hatte halt ein erhebliches Problem mit einem seiner größten Kunden, nämlich der Deutschen Bank. Weil die Deutsche Bank fand es gar nicht lustig, dass sie dann mitgeteilt bekam, dass ihr Schlüssel halt nicht für ihr internes Netzwerk, dass sie mit Lotus Notes aufbauen, halt irgendwie nur 40 Bit lang ist, was man irgendwie mit einem besseren PC machen kann, in Anführungszeichen. Statt der erwarteten 56 Bit, also sie haben da erhebliche Probleme und da gibt es halt nur die verschiedensten Lösungsansätze. Einerseits gibt es halt einen starken Druck von den amerikanischen Firmen, diese Exportbeschränkungen zu lockern. Andererseits hat die Clinton-Administration also eine Falle aufgebaut, zu sagen, ok, ihr könnt jetzt erstmal bestimmte Sachen exportieren, aber ihr müsst euch verpflichten, dass ihr Schlüsselhinterlegungsmechanismen innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre implementiert.
Das ist ja bekannt, aber also den Ursprung zurückzukommen. Also ich war gezwungen, ziemlich kurzfristig, und zwar ohne, dass ich jetzt kurz Zeit investieren konnte, mir so eine Verschleißung dazu zulegen, weil ich meine, es ging um Geschäftsdaten, und da war für mich die Sache einmal frei. Ich hatte bisher noch kein PGP, also habe ich mir kurzfristig besorgt. Da habe ich mir Gedanken gemacht, wie kriege ich es am besten und wie umgehe ich die Restriktion. Und damit habe ich mich ganz einfach über PGP eingelegt, über einen Ring mehr.
Wie gesagt, die PGP ist praktisch auf allen großen europäischen Servern verfügbar. Und es gibt mittlerweile auch von einer belgischen Firma zum Beispiel Implementierungen für Mac und so weiter. Die Software ist so weit verbreitet, dass sie nicht mehr zu stoppen ist. Man muss da auch nicht zwingend gegen amerikanische Exportrestriktionen verstoßen, um sich diese Software zu besorgen, weil man ein bisschen Kitzel haben will, ein bisschen Abenteuer kann man es natürlich tun.
Und noch ist das alles hier ganz legal?
Genau, noch kann man hier tun, was man will.
In meiner Frage, inwiefern ist denn gesichert, oder gibt es neben PGP genauso sichere, jetzt mal in Anführungsstrichen, Verschlussungsverfahren?
PGP ist ja nur eine Implementation von RSA. Und der großen Vorteil oder der Vertrauensvorschuss, den man da irgendwie hineinlegt, entsteht ja daraus, dass PGP im Source Code vorliegt. Das heißt, dass jeder sich den Programm Code angucken kann, ihn verstehen kann. Hingegen andere Programme oder Geräte, die man sich kauft, die verschütteln, da weiß man im Grunde genommen zwar, was diese Geräte tun, aber man weiß blöderweise nicht, was diese Geräte noch tun. Es gab da mal einen Spiegelartikel über die Firma, wie heißt die, Crypto AG in der Schweiz, da heißt es dann so schön, dagegen den unbefugten Dritten schützen diese Geräte, ganz bestimmt. Aber was wir mit dem befugten Vierten machen, das können wir Ihnen leider nicht sagen. Also das ist da letztlich der Punkt.
Also es gibt von der Qualität von PGP, es gibt verschiedene Algorithmen, die halt im Internet auch heftig debattiert werden. So ein Kandidat wäre da Blowfish, der halt von einem der Heronen der Kryptographie entwickelt wurde. Die Forschung geht da halt weiter, auch gerade im akademischen Bereich, und es entstehen neue Algorithmen. Nur bei Algorithmen, die halt auf ungelöst mathematischen Problemen beruhen, ist es halt so, dass es nur eine Negativ-Aussage dazu gibt, wenn sie halt geknackt sind. Ansonsten kann man halt nur dazu sagen, sie sind halt nicht geknackt, weil es bis jetzt noch niemand geschafft hat. Im Groben gesagt. Und Algorithmen, die halt relativ neu sind, also wie zum Beispiel Blowfish, die müssen halt erstmal noch eine Weile im Kreuzfeuer der Experten bestehen, bevor man sagen kann, die sind jetzt halt wirklich so vertrauenswert wie PGP. PGP ist ja eine Kombination aus RSA und IDEA, also zwei verschiedenen Verschlussungsverfahren.
Wie sieht's denn eigentlich aus mit, ich hab nicht alles gehört von euch, hab da eigentlich auch schon darüber diskutiert, die Dinge in Bildern zu verstecken.
Steganografie haben wir noch nicht erwähnt.
Vielleicht machen wir noch eine Musik.
Es geht ja jetzt auch mehr um den politischen Aspekt bei der Verschlüsselung, nicht so sehr jetzt um die Verschlüsselungstechniken selber, dass wir eben der Auffassung sind, dass verhindert werden sollte, dass private Kryptographie verboten wird.
wie in den Staaten, dass sich ganz einfach Millionen Leute dazu aufraffen, mal eine Zeit lang alles zu verschlüsseln, und ich glaube dann sind auch die Rechner der NSA irgendwann mal überlebt. Also das machen wir auf dem Wege des Protestes, also des zivilen Ungeheuers, wie man das auch mal nennt.
Ja, da kam ja gerade noch die Frage mit der Steganografie. Vielleicht noch ein Wort dazu für die Erhörer, die da nicht so erfahren sind. Steganografie ist ein Verfahren, mit dem man Botschaften in anderen Dingen verstecken kann. Also ein einfaches Beispiel wäre zum Beispiel, man nimmt sich ein Bild, das in digitaler Form vorliegt, und da sind ja die Farben kodiert. Und wenn man sich jetzt eine Farbe nimmt, wo man den Unterschied von einem zu anderen nicht so richtig feststellen kann, kann man darin Informationen übertragen, wenn man sich verändern hat. Und mit Hilfe dieser Steganografie kann man halt verschlüsselte Botschaften in anderen Bildern, die eigentlich harmlos sind, verbergen, sodass eigentlich niemand mehr richtig feststellen kann, dass eine verschlüsselte Botschaft da drin ist, ist ja dann, man weiß, wie sie darin verborgen ist.
Wobei das jetzt nicht verschlüsselt im Sinne von kriptifiziert ist, sondern...
Versteckt.
Also man sollte natürlich zusätzlich dabei auch noch verschlüsseln. Also das ist halt eine Methode, um halt diverse Gehandlungskomputer irrezuführen.
Und vor allem...
Die halt nach verschlüsselten Geschichten suchen.
Na und vor allem, um klar zu machen, warum der Verbot von Verschlüsseln ein verantwortlich unsinnig ist, weil dazu muss man erstmal feststellen können, dass das überhaupt eingesetzt wird.
Das ist übrigens eines der ältesten Verschlüsselungsverfahren überhaupt früher wurde. Das nämlich eingesetzt, indem man einfach lange Texte geschrieben hat. Und so war zum Beispiel von jedem dritten Wort der Anfangsbuchstabe ein Buchstabe des Textes, den man eigentlich verübermitteln wurde. Die Texte waren dann vielleicht so ein bisschen merkwürdig in der Wortwahl, aber keineswegs auffällig und enthielten einen völlig lapidanen Text. Zum Beispiel auch ein Liebesbrief, den ja die NSA gar nicht entschlüsseln will, sodass also tatsächlich mit diesen Verfahren auch Botschaften früher schon ausgetauscht wurden.
Ich denke auch, das wesentliche Punkt ist dann doch wohl die Wirtschaftsspionage, wo es einfach um konkrete Informationen geht, bei täglichem Nachrichtenaustausch. So, das war Chaos Radio im März. Kontrolle elektronischer Medien. Wir sind jetzt alle am Ende. Ist doch alle krank, fast alle. Schön, dass zumindest Andi heute durchgehenden Redefluss gehabt hat. Zum Abschluss noch ein paar Informationen zum Chaos Computer Club.
Das werden wir gleich noch im Auto diskutieren.
Der Chaos Computer Club ist auf dem Internet erreichbar unter www.ccc.de. Da gibt es derzeit auch lustige Sachen zu finden. So ist gerade erschienen die neue Datenschleuder. Die gibt es zwar nicht online zu lesen, aber wie ihr es bestellen könnt.
Die gibt es auch in der Schubänkerstraße 85 in 20255 Hamburg.
Außerdem haben wir noch ein paar andere lustige Neuigkeiten. Es gibt Chaos T-Shirts und demnächst die Chaos CD des Chaos Computer Clubs.
Also es gibt T-Shirts mit dem altbekannten Alt F4 Logo. Die werden noch bestellbar sein, aber da arbeiten wir noch dran. Das erwartet dann auf www.ccde oder in der Datenschleuder. Oder bei der nächsten Radiosendung oder im Internet.
Die Chaos CD enthält alle alten Datenschleudern und vor allem auch die immer wieder hinterfragten alten Hackerbibeln.
Ist aber im Moment nur in einer Beta-Version verfügbar. Das heißt, die Sachen sind da teilweise als Gift, also als Bild drauf und werden sozusagen zur dezentralen OCR-ung an Mitglieder und von mir aus auch Interessierte für 42 Mark plus Porto bei der üblichen Hamburger Anschrift, Gegenüberweisung, V-Shack, Bar, sonst weh abgegeben. Und was war noch?
Ansonsten so wird glaube ich am Ende.
Und einen schönen Abendachten.